today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza
today's episode is also presented to you
by
nuh-nuh-nuh-nuh naw thurr than ridge
wallet and ridge wallet is you know
everybody used to have a wallet in the
back of their pants which i think
honestly sounds a little bit dirty but
it's nice to know that now people are
doing something different people are on
the cusp on the precipice of novice
ideas and wallet tree and one of those
precipices is the ridge ridge wallet
it's a front pocket carry tired of just
wondering where your money is and
realizing it's right on your butt in the
back of your pants well now you can have
your money up front with you moving
forward just like you are visit Ridge
wallet dot-com slash theö and use code
théo at checkout for 10%
that's code theo th EO for 10% off at
Ridge wallet dot-com slash Theo it's
Christmas time so get a Ridge wallet
today's episode is I mean it's a special
type of man you know every time and
every now and then you run into a real a
sensei if you will and this man is that
you know he's kind of that you know he's
kind of that uh you know a little bit of
that kind of Latino Vietnamese sort of
male Rapunzel you know I mean he's just
up and down the walls you know and and
he's a really talented man he's the
first two-time guest that we've had here
on this past weekend and there was some
contention the episode we didn't get it
out and then like the files kind of
disappeared and they finally popped back
up and so you know I'm not saying any
I'm look into it that's all I'm saying
but um but here we are happy to have
them the second time and happy to at
last get this episode out here on this
past weekend mr. Eddie Bravo
[Music]
you're drinking an energy drink what I
feel like you I can't even imagine when
you wake up it must be like is it
intense what does it feel like he seemed
like it see cuz I feel like some people
wake up in like no way
no and I feel like you had my ass really
yeah yeah I think you would wake up
standing up already Mike honestly man no
man I wish I wish
would you ever wish I was one of them
now man I've always been horrible
morning person yeah horrible
now what would whenever you were a kid
like what was it like that your mom like
did you guys did you share room with her
brother something what was it like when
you were a kid and you woke up your mom
coming back time for school like what
was that like
well man growing up between five and 10
mm-hmm I got up early and got the [ __ ]
to school as quickly as possible because
I had a stepdad living with us and he
was uh he wasn't cool no no no cuz he he
was my stepdad but he was my older
brother and younger sisters real dad oh
wow the brother so my mom married
Alfonso Bravo had my brother Alfonso jr.
they divorced right mom's single with
the kid with my brother she always
wanted to be a singer so she's always
out the clubs and she met this club
promoter my dad my my logical dad who's
married with five kids but um
my mom was a little hottie when when she
was you know like 18 and he you know he
saw her in line just dragged her and
gave her that VIP you you can han so he
was all over my mom and they started
dating he and he was married it was a
weird situation he got her pregnant with
me got her
she would my whole family including her
was from its from Santa Ana California
that's where they put all the Mexicans
right you know cuz all the white people
in the 60s they left that land there's a
too many Mexicans so there you have yeah
so they went down to Orange County El
Toro
Laguna Niguel all that [ __ ] Irvine they
were they were escaping the Mexicans but
in Santa Anas would have a lot of cars
people do like a lot of cool cars and
stuff but they [ __ ] up they thought
they could escape but were they gonna
put the people to clean their [ __ ] you
know what I mean cut the grass and all
that so that a lot of the service
initially they got to bring that yes you
guys ignite a city for the Mexicans for
those banana and that was Santa Ana Wow
so all around Santa Ana was white people
but that's where they put the Mexican so
in there for you guys were yeah then I'm
but my mom went to downtown LA to go
clubbing back in the in this in the 60s
and met my dad then he moved her he got
her an apartment he was still married
Wow that was his little side piece on
the side got a side piece that already
had a kid who's pregnant and he was
telling my mom he was gonna divorce his
wife when he had five kids and but she
wouldn't allow the divorce she thought
she was hardcore religious Catholic and
thought you know divorced men you're
going to hell yeah so she wouldn't grant
him the divorce so then he started
telling her that was so nice of your mom
that wasn't it like your mom's like I
don't want you to get divorced from that
lady because no no no no no no not my
mom
his wife Oh his wife says as his wife
wouldn't know she says the what you sued
the guy was gonna marry your mother yeah
my mom wanted him to get her divorce
okay and then his wife was like no we're
not gonna do that because of people what
people think etc and she did want to go
to hell Wow so he couldn't get a divorce
that's what he said maybe maybe you know
this is maybe the story is a little
different but that's the story that I
got so they he never divorced her so my
mom eventually you know had my kid and
he would tell he would tell his wife and
his kids about my mom and that she's
pregnant and when I was born like oh I
had he was evil evil he was tell him all
about it he brought his wife
over to the apartment to see his son me
know yeah if you think that a control
thing you think he did that he's it must
have been a control like I want to be
able to control the whole situation so
I'm gonna show the late I'm gonna have
every I'm gonna have everybody meet
everybody so then it's like I'm the
facilitator you think maybe or maybe it
was just a driver insane to make her too
bright I don't know I don't know what it
was but he did that they he brought like
I just had a son you want to go meet him
to his wife and then it was you this
crazy wild son
yeah and then so my mom had enough she
said [ __ ] this clown she went back to
Orange County Santa Anna and now she got
two sons my older brother Alfonso
Alfonso and me with a different dad so
she wants Owen
Eddie dude so so her hit my biological
father's last name is Cano mmm-hmm so
that was my last name but what ended up
happening was when my mom moved back to
Santa Ana she started dating Alfonso
Bravo again oh wow original [ __ ] she
went back she went back started dating
him I remember that [ __ ] and were you
excited at first you remember [ __ ] no
really I was you known him the whole
time and knew how he was no I didn't I
didn't know him I just I just
he was I didn't know him at all wasn't
even born you know I just heard about
him my grandfather hated her my mom's
father hated him because he would beat
her I was a [ __ ]
he was an alcoholic and just an elastic
yeah just classic egomania wife beater
Oh classic wife beater and my
grandfather wanted to kill him my
grandfather liked my dad though is what
my mom was dating my dad even though he
was married he took my grandfather was
cool he they got along great you know
what I mean and they played cards
together there were and he was about
thirteen years older than my mom mm-hmm
you know so he was like almost like
right yeah my grandfather take so my
grandfather had my mom when he was like
so he really liked my dad my stepdad but
my mom went back with my stepdad hmm and
got he got her pregnant
why did your mom do that do you think
she you know she was in love was that
she was at love in love at one point and
she was young and she gave him another
chance he got her pregnant so once he
got her pregnant I was five when my
sister was born that's so I have an
older brother younger sister same father
I met receiver thing at The Comedy Store
right is that her or the sister-in-law
sister-in-law sister-in-law my
sister-in-law so uh then at five they
decide to try it again but now Here I am
you know I'm the kid that you're the
battleground
I'm the reminder of what my mom was
messin with another guy you know what I
mean so he [ __ ] hated dude I could
have been you if I contain the reminder
he [ __ ] hated me man he [ __ ] hate
we know we never I never called him dad
from the age of five to ten we lived
together it was it was dark he always
looked at me like he'd like if he could
yeah if he could but you were probably
ready to take him on a temper you know I
was terrified really to commit suicide
I'll try to deal on a bottle of ther
grand em you know my vitamins yeah I try
to OD on vitamins when would you get
just better I just fell asleep I didn't
have they didn't have oxycontin's back
there I thank God huh yeah you know what
if they would have you know yeah so how
were you were you that sad about like
were you like did it make you sad or to
make you just angry do you even remember
like what that was like he was just a
dick man like I like this is that all
that was a setup - did I wake up early
right
between ages of five and ten I woke up
her early to get the [ __ ] out of Dodge
Wow because my mom she woke up super
early like she'd be gone by 5:30 to go
to work but he didn't have to leave to
the balik's like 7:00 7:30 so it would
be and my brother my brother slept late
so I would I would be up with him
the morning yeah so I was just you know
I would eat cereal and he'd be at the
other side of the table he would just
sit there and just stare at me he would
do [ __ ] that I couldn't report you know
he would just sit there and stare at me
and then when I was done with my food he
did this [ __ ] all the time when I would
walk to the kitchen he would stand up
and block the doorway to the kitchen oh
so then I would have to walk I'm a
little eight-year-old kid right I'd have
to go outside the front door walk around
the side of the house go through the
back door just to put my plate away but
it was like normal and even just have a
smile on his face he would just he just
did evil [ __ ] like that dude that's evil
bro yeah yeah yeah so and you know if he
added he had he had a chance to beat our
ass oh you had an excuse oh man oh [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah what me and my brother we
would we would NFL pencils when a kid in
selamat school for ten sentences were
nice to me what do you want yeah yeah
what do you want nobody was a Tampa Bay
Buccaneers
hell no nobody wanted Tampa Bay back
then because back then they were right
when they were expanding they were an
expansion team like 1978 there were 116
or something so we would go steal
pencils and we got caught and my brother
got caught I didn't get caught he got
caught I'm waiting outside of the store
they take him upstairs to the office and
I'm wearing oh [ __ ] we're gonna be bust
my step that's gonna [ __ ] us up I was
freaking out I didn't know what to do so
I waited I waited for about an hour you
know that I finally went inside and one
of the guys came out and said oh your
parents already picked him up you know
and I said oh [ __ ] I ran home was like a
two-mile run dude I ran home so what are
you running home for because if you're
gonna get in trouble you just you figure
out what the figure I think I just blame
it on you or somehow do you think you
don't have to find better get there I
got to find out what the [ __ ] is going
on this could be death so I get home
I'll never forget I get home this is
like a la Bamba the deleted scenes you
know I get home and I look down there's
a long hallway to our bedroom because
you know my brother shared rooms me and
my stepdad is had had my my brothers
shirt off and this is his real blood and
he's whipping
like come to Ken today he had belt to
bear back and had him and he's washed
and I looked down the hallway dude and
he had the belt and he looked back at me
dude down the hallway and he smiled and
he came for me and and it was that my
mom saved my life you know what I mean
he was a dominant one
whatever he [ __ ] said went yeah but
when it came to that Sheena he was gonna
kill me
Wow so she jumped between us like Big
John McCarthy man and [ __ ] stop that
[ __ ] and she beat the hell out of me but
that was fine as long as he didn't get
to and he even knew it he even knew it
he understood he's like I have the best
excuse to beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
right now after they hands and you know
what it's probably better that I don't
cuz I'll probably murder this kid my mom
my mom literally saved my life right
there it was crazy so and where's that
guy at now I don't know and really he
took up when we found we we would do
anything me and my brother my brother
hated him and I was his real dad and we
would do we would do any extracurricular
activities to get out of the goddamn
house so we joined the Boy Scouts so we
weren't a Boy Scout trip once and when
we came back I was ten my brother was 14
and when we got back my mom is beat the
[ __ ] up her hair's all ratted and she's
got like all she's all beaten were like
what happened mom and she told us he
beat the [ __ ] out of her got dragged her
outside by her hair grabbed her and
dragged like those world start hip-hop
videos yeah dragged her by the hair
dragged her out beat her ass in the
front front yard but my uncle live next
door he came out with a shotgun yeah
he's gonna blow his ass away and he just
got his keys got in his car left all his
[ __ ] he left all this [ __ ] took off and
we never I never saw ice we didn't see
him for years I mean I ended up seeing
him cuz he was still tight with my
sister and my sister got married and I'd
see a man a you know every now and then
like I got her wedding or something like
that I mean I said you don't ever take
it out with him did you ever want to get
revenge on him [ __ ] yeah I want her in
[ __ ] bed
yeah I want her new dad but I mean I was
10 when he filing that but when
when my mother told us me and my brother
Mike holy [ __ ] she's crying he's gone
him and we're thinking is he gone for
good
right you know as if it was her always
like a little bit of here that he could
pop back up and she basically said yes
he's gain coming back and we slowly
walked down that long hallway me and my
brother we got to our room [ __ ] we
closed the door dude we started jumping
for joy on our bed we were jumping yeah
because we knew with him gone
she with him God we're on the streets
like wild animals dude we got to do it I
really like this is gonna be like a
heartwarming story another mom yeah it's
under control
right he had us under control we live
our lives we were I mean he that the
neighborhood kids they would make fun of
us because we were always cutting the
grass and cleaning cleaning cutting the
grass remember that sound bye remember
that movie car wash and that that's it
well work and work I I forget how the
lyrics go but that that song
the kids would sing that [ __ ] while we
were working on my car I never play in
areas you know so and we had to have his
orange juice ready oh we got home [ __ ]
he better have all [ __ ] a gallon of
fresh orange juice ready to go cuz we
had connections as Mexicans you have
countries for juice and then beats a
woman on orange juice orange juice was
the key to him we had next couple doors
down there was a guy you know with all
Latino song it's all Mexican it's all
Mexican man there's almost all Mexicans
with single single moms you know all the
husband's left they eventually left it
was just a bunch of kids on the street
single moms and we had a guy down the
street who picked oranges for a living
they're everywhere so we would get these
gigantic sacks like army better [ __ ] um
through it there were five bucks yeah
five bucks and we had to have that
orange juice ready you know what he got
us for Christmas well an electric orange
juice maker man really yeah and we were
kind of happy about it we're like that's
like he's hot
sure does you know we would do it like
this manually you know but then when you
got that electrical he was it was orange
- you just press down and it spins for
you that was huge
Wow oh so you think he did that actually
like a nice thing yeah like he was
trying to hook us up right but at the
same time the same time if you're gonna
be working but I'm gonna make it look
easy
exactly but dude I'm gonna whip you know
we're gonna you know it's gonna be a
different kind of leather that's soft
dude I remember that orange juice thing
you'd push on it and then you would reel
it massage your hand once it got low
enough you know talking about it was
just the Rhynie look like a nettle juice
was good that's fresh-squeezed do we
which I would [ __ ] drink it right out
of the jug and then put water and it to
replace that did my brother or somebody
some neighbor occasion put his butt on
that thing and [ __ ] put like his
butthole on that or instead that thing
and just spin around bro yeah some local
party ever felt great but was that so
like were there a lot of my so like so
at that point this is interesting is it
for me I didn't know like about some of
this history so it was all so there was
like this white flight kind of thing but
then there were like a lot of the
service industry which is predominantly
Mexican they all lived in Santa Ana yeah
that's where they put them and what was
the neighborhood like was it fun was it
cool was it it doesn't like it was
awesome dude it was just as soon as my
stepdad was gone at 10:00 yeah from
10:00 on it was awesome just a bunch of
wild Mexican kids on the street it was
weird because this the street that we
lived on 6th Street and 6th Street and
Bristol and all around us were like
traditional Mexican you know like
musically like like no no I meant more
like more the gangbanger type Mexicans
all around but it all is that called a
cholo cholo tribe yeah basically when
you go to junior high school uh-huh if
you're Mexican you have to claim a gang
even though you're not in a gang you
have to get to be part of a club and you
have to be dressed a certain way right
you go home you can dress any way you
want but when you go to school you got
it you got to have Levi's scores that
are creased or or or Dickies that are
crying yeah you have to you have to
dress the part right and it's by dress
but everybody on that block we were
we were all into classic rock like it
was a bunch of Mexican tell me that yeah
we're all into like the kid across
you're growing long hair and stuff is
different it was like yes so when I went
to when I finally went to junior high at
the sixth grade I refused to dress like
a cholo I just went and looked like like
a white guy I would wear like Ocean
Pacific so if you were to rock back then
in the early 80s wore like surfer type
clothes right you know what I mean
yeah I don't know if you remember
lightning bolt that brand like it's an
old surfer Brad lightning bolt ocean
Pacific Ocean Pacific I remember I still
have a certain how its Opie pants Opie
shorts Opie shirts yeah and then like so
I'd go I went to sixth grade in junior
high and I got man I got messed with for
a lot of reasons and one of the reasons
was I wasn't acting Mexican enough
how were you defiant though so this is
interesting to me so were you now what
made you were you like defiant of the
Mexican culture so not that you didn't
want to be but what was there something
like you didn't want to assembly do you
want to be different like what was it
what was the cause of some of that I was
just so into rock man I wasn't the kid
music gosh yeah oh the music dude the
music brainwash the [ __ ] out of me hey
goddamn you zyk got me hook line and
sinker you know I was chasing mansions
and I wanted to be now every tell me you
want to be a rock and roll star you want
to do David Lee Roth you know what I
mean I want her to be kiss I wanted to
you know and who did everybody else want
to be like who did all the Latino kids
want to be all my friends want you know
who knows what they want to be my
friends we you know we formed a pan and
we want to know we wanted right you guys
want yeah you guys were getting in a row
right away man so the music just took
our souls over and we were always in the
football too right when the football I
the two things I want I was really
Americanized they totally not in a bad
way but you guys were very Americanized
I wanted to either be a football player
right or a rockstar I was I was pursuing
both right you know and I didn't realize
there was no chance at being a football
player until ninth grade yeah that's
when I realized [ __ ] no there's no
Mexicans playing football Mexicans don't
I think Marcus Mariota max
Latino that's like there's no Chinese
playing people playing football now you
don't realize that though because when
you when I played football in 1979 I was
nine years old and your junior
all-american all the kids are the same
size you girl American everybody I was
playing I was playing defensive line a
middle linebacker really [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and and that's what I got
I'm at nine I'm like you know what woman
I'm gonna I'm gonna be a football player
in the NFL and I'll be playing middle
linebacker probably I like defense I
didn't realize that you know that was
never gonna have one you happen so but
now was there any like like what is it
like if you don't fit into Mexican
culture was there any of that was there
any kickback from like more traditional
oh yeah my family my family really loud
giant Mexican family my mom had nine
brothers and sisters and all my aunts we
were all tight we were all close and
they were into mariachis and my
mariachis that's traditional and in my
family mariachis are huge and you know
I'm a 12 year old 13 year old kid in
Mexican weddings and Mexican
quinceañeras and they're playing Mexican
music and I'm like [ __ ] I wish they
would play our made you know long hair
just the the depressed just just always
pissed off little kid oh yeah I mean
I've got a psycho in America yeah you
know and I was just getting the metallic
and [ __ ] and we're at some Mexican
wedding I went I hate him I was um I was
a terrible kid I really was you know you
look at all our our pictures from
weddings and stuff there's everyone
everywhere looks normal and there I am
all depressed in the wedding [ __ ]
outfit that they put and my hair my hair
is long yeah my hair is long and I just
I just want to go play music or
something you know is this was but it
seems like there's some rebellion in
there we just had the photos nature
totally totally yeah I was rebelling
against everything do you feel like like
you didn't wanna be part like I've never
wanted to be part of me as always not
wanting to be part of a group like
there's something about me like I'm
happy to be in a group I'm happy to have
a group of friends stuff like that
but when it really comes to somebody
been like oh you're part of this like no
no immediately I want to find a
different angle or my own angle or
something I do not I don't there's
something about me I do not you know I
don't it does I don't feel I don't know
I don't like being part of a group or
said that I'm part of a group you know
that would be hard to say because I was
you know forming right your user group
so right we were part of a group you
know and we were part of the metal scene
and you know but you guys weren't
outliers at that time it seemed like in
the area in the area from for the
Mexicans so I'm in 6th grade and I'm my
my grandmother and my mom had kids at
the same time so I had no is that like a
Man Thing
what's that called my mom had kids early
and and my grandmother had kids late you
know so I had two aunts Alice and Paddy
that were two years old he but everyone
thought there were my sisters there were
two years older than me we were tight
and we were tired you know when when my
stepdad was around I could I couldn't
wait to go to my grandmother's house
which was three blocks away and stay
there and hang out with house and Patty
my aunt is it fun it was so much fun and
I love my grandma to death and my
grandfather it was that was heaven right
there I just wanted to be at my
grandmother's house all the time I
didn't want to be in the same house with
you know cuz me and my brother we didn't
we have you know your classic sibling
rivalry you know four years older than
me always trying to humiliate me in
front of the neighborhood kids you know
the class yeah you know so I hated him
too
yeah I hated my stepfather my mom was
always working and and it was tough so
that was really growing up that was my
that was that my nightmares that I have
today yeah the nightmares I have today
always take place at that house ah with
some different [ __ ] yeah there's always
take place and it's that house like I
find myself and my the house I grew up
in but with like modern people and
sharing makes sense and one of them but
the stress there's just such a [ __ ] just
like I the nightmares were like some I
find myself
I'll never some things you never forget
and this is one nightmare I'll never
forget and this is like common where I'm
I'm sitting in the living room with my
stepdad there and like my mom and we're
watching TV and then I look around and
there everyone's gone and then when
everyone's gone that's when this evil
from you can't see it it's like under
the bed around the corner in the hallway
and it's coming to get me
it's like this evil force and I'm all
alone and I ran out I run to the the
living room look out the window well
I'll never forget this video in my it's
like a video in my head of my mom and
grabbing my running away with my brother
and my sister and they're like leaving
and I'm in this house and I can't get
out of it I never forget that one so is
uh it wasn't a great childhood yeah but
um you know me when I was like a pie it
sound like such a simmering pot it just
sounds like such a place for like yeah
if your stepdad if you can't see him or
what he's doing then there's always this
[ __ ] unser was tough it was tough man
it was tough and when my stepdad was
gone it was tough for my mom she had to
raise three kids he left he left the
country went back to Mexico no left left
his credit card debt of course he did he
left it and everything in a [ __ ] my
mom financed she was making $150 a week
so she was always working overtime she
worked hard my mom my mom worked [ __ ]
the hard for us and on Fridays no matter
what
on Fridays were going to McDonald's
really yeah we were like hell yeah you
know what you got [ __ ] is the same I'm
on with the Mayo fish baby
I still eat those that's still my
dessert if I want to cheat if I'm gonna
cheat I'm gonna go get that filet-o-fish
are you kidding okay yeah it's the fish
dude I don't even know we could order
the fish sauce like thirty years old my
mom got the fish so I got into it too it
was never really in the Big Macs but I
do like just I just even still today I
order like I'm just yeah there's just a
little a little ya pair of them yeah
[ __ ] if you're the highest [ __ ] and
you're like [ __ ] it's Sunday gonna
watch some good medically
I'll go get me some filet-o-fish and two
cheeseburgers and a large and maybe that
hot fudge sundae no nuts
triple fudge Oh
come back and say we can't do triple
fudge cuz they won't be room for ice
cream and I always come back I'll
sacrifice ice cream pull that some of
that ice cream out and place it with
fudge I just want like half of the fudge
you know what I mean make it fit don't
we say mark yeah I guess a triple fudge
we can't do triple fudge it won't fit
sacrifice cream don't put no nuts in I
share these nuts it distracts from five
it's that hot fudge than I really want
that is good man every now and then I'll
do that and it's horrible you know but
you see I win every Friday I went out to
the Madonna
McDonald's right there at Bristol on 17
and there was a karate studio next
nextdoor where the white kids cuz that
was like an outskirts where white people
started there's some parts of Santa Anna
with white people didn't want to admit
it where they actually live in Santa
Anna it says that on your mail but
they'll say now we live in Tustin we
live in Orange like [ __ ] you still
Hannah let me look at your mail
but the white people were ashamed to say
Santa Anna cuz everybody knew he lived
in Santa it's like saying you live in
East LA right you know and so then we
had this karate school next door mm-hmm
and man I looked at to me there was just
unattainable
like what it's not like 30 bucks off yes
only the rich get 30 bucks a bag
karate are you really thirty bucks a
month in 1980 was probably about a $200
a month yeah and that was never gonna
happen but man I was fascinated with
that karate I was I was afraid to go in
there and look you know and like what
about it though like what about it like
what you just I think I think naturally
everybody wants to be able to defend
themselves right naturally everybody of
if there was a button you could press
that gave you self-defense skills mm-hmm
everybody would press it there wouldn't
be anybody that's true impressive right
but you can't press it right all you got
to do is go to the gym that's precedent
right but instead of taking like half a
second to press it take six months a
year two years well it's the exact same
thing yeah so I thought it was on a
table Mike
would really love to learn how to fight
because in school people fight I got in
fights in school no were you ant like
would you make fun of people were you
like an ass or were you just kind of
like just different you think um it all
depends man it all depends I was an
[ __ ] if I could be yeah but if I
couldn't be an instigator maybe it all
depends on the teacher right if I had a
teacher who I gave two teachers a
nervous breakdown okay
they were a Miss Franklin 8th grade
history and a Miss Aspen 10th grade
English and you feel bad about that I do
feel bad about that
I would I would kick my ass if I could
you know if did you ever reach out to
all doesn't no no no but there were the
kind of teachers that were super loving
I wanted everyone to express themselves
so then I just became the class clown
yeah I just got everyone just involved
and and drove them [ __ ] nuts you know
at but same here 10th grade first first
period mr. Enders he ain't take [ __ ] and
he said how quad its [ __ ] oh I think
everybody tell me about this actually
yeah okay so it all depends it all
depends on on who was teaching me or who
I'm around like I played Little League
baseball and I sucked I led the league
and strikeouts
I was Darrell ball I remember cracking
one ball pop fly to center field the guy
caught it was like right to the guy the
guy and you know I was all right I don't
care that he got it I just thought this
is great that was a highl I cracked a
ball and you know what you know what I
was good up I was good at bunting really
cuz literally an [ __ ] yeah I was fun
and they could they would always
overthrow it or throw it wrong at first
so I don't get to I'd get the first or
second base once but if I had to swing
it was like I was I was cursed
I could not connect with that yeah but
that's my same thing huh one time I hit
it out in the field I was like that's a
[ __ ] homerun and I was literally just
right over the set it was like yeah I
was the easiest I was always the scrub
but you know there's a cut-off
ADEs weren't like that you can't at 13
you can't play Little League no more
right you guys start playing like junior
high school ball it was like 12 or 13
somebody wanna be in a pervert but my
birthday gives a dirty still paying it
my birthday was at a spot where they're
like you know everyone you know most of
my teammates weren't you got to hang
around i got to hang out one more year
but i didn't want to because i suck but
the coach said dude hang out one more
year you're gonna have advantage over
these kids most of the kids gonna be
young and now you're gonna be good I
mean you'll be better yeah I'm like I
didn't want to do it but I did and
talked me into it
even better ice know I still sucked but
because I was older than the kids yeah
they wanted me as the leader Oh
so I still suck but now I'm a leader so
you like William walls like in his
skills I just became an ass I was just
an [ __ ] and you know they play though
where do you where do you put the worst
baseball player yeah the one guy sucks
no right field right field because every
most people right-hander yeah I feel bad
too laughter so then I was in Roberts oh
but I was in right field and I thought
it was the left well we got a guy named
Raphael young guy Raphael he played
right field and not only was you the
worst player on the team but he had a
one of them plastic glove we bought his
blood like at a liquor store you know
what I mean if you bought like it tennis
shoes or a glove at a liquor store
damn you're real poor yeah we weren't
that point right he bought the shitty
shoes the shitty we got the real we
never would buy it my mom would never
let us buy shoes at a liquor store yeah
that was that's what she drew the line
Yeah right
so now guy Anarkali groovy he had like a
hat and he just taped it to his [ __ ]
hand and his dad painted it brown so
this guy being I was frustrated cuz I
sucked but I'm like this leader right
I'm just an ass hold everybody sound
like I'm holy in my heart yeah one time
I have to practice I'm just talking [ __ ]
on Raphael the worst the worst player
talk to [ __ ] on his second team on the
team well yeah he was worse than me
right he was my players I could at least
catch right you know he was striking out
just like I don't know right
we were the strikeout Kings who leaned
the leak but I can catch the goddamn
right I could catch it and I could throw
ok let me pitch I pitch one yo sound
like the words [ __ ] - yeah Bad News
Bears they would have [ __ ] us up but I
started talking [ __ ] after practicing
we're just I'm just being a dick and he
got he just snapped and he got me in a
headlock and put me on the grass and he
wouldn't let go he wasn't punching me
but he wouldn't let go and I was trapped
in a headlock and I couldn't get out I
was panicking telling the please let me
go let me go
he totally humiliated and what's that
movement you just right there
I [ __ ] walk this guy I learned my
lesson I learned the talking [ __ ] like
that he put you in that plastic glove
baby he [ __ ] took you to the bank he
he had that rage where he was I was not
gonna lose he was not gonna let go my
head ma and I could not get my [ __ ]
hat out and if you would you be able to
take a knife you got rolling small
unless you know he's doing jujitsu
I think you'd want to you know it'd be a
good bet to put the money on my side but
you know anything could happen
my cold [ __ ] me you know what I mean do
this is ever guaranteed tell about who
throws that first punch right if you
weren't at the McDonald's do you think
you get into karate do you think you get
into that universe or not somehow you
still find them if you weren't if you if
your mother doesn't take you to that
McDonald's on Fridays do you think you
end up in that universe that world yeah
man once ice once I saw Bruce Lee once
that was it yeah I'm a Bruce Lee fanatic
but I always I never thought I could
afford martial arts right so I got
really into Bruce Lee I was I mean I got
fanatically into him but I just never
thought I I was always broke yeah you
know even because I saw the guy and
everything all my extra money went to
buying musical equipment I always had
drunk cuz I was a drummer originally I
was at drum equipment to buy and
everything was just all about buying
musical equipment getting a car so I
could transport my drums to practice you
know what I mean yeah so he never had
any money for for martial arts at all
you know yeah until until I moved to
Hollywood for music and I thought is
1991 and I thought okay you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna conquer the music
business so I gotta look good while I'm
on stage so I started I went to a gym
first of all to try to lift weights to
look good
lasted ten minutes I said okay I can't
do that
so I go man maybe I could afford some
martial arts so I looked at some martial
arts schools around my where I lived in
my work time to karate place started
doing karate and I loved it so I write
but you got in there do you did they did
the people who are running the facility
or where do they think that you excelled
at this like oh this is something that
you do well or do you feel that they
told you no they tell everybody that oh
yeah that's true they tell they they
just blow a lot of smoke up your ass
ya know you're gonna be a killer you're
gonna be a fighting machine look at that
stance yeah and they told me next time I
turn you're trying to turn yourself like
in a Japanese or something you know they
told me my instructor told me he said I
was a white belt and my first stripe my
first green stripe took a little test
how to do one kata and he said that I
have a awesome
overhand nice strike was one of these
boom so I was like oh [ __ ] that's my
[ __ ] so I'm and I wasn't a kid I was 22
years old thinking to a grown man
thinking hey you better watch out for
that overhead nice strike and now you
got a name to it to you this term I was
a grown man so I went I was training and
I was training six months I was training
six months and if someone told me that
were training six months jujitsu and we
were gonna roll to me six months there's
nothing you're gonna be able to do
that's actually nothing but or you could
look at it like damn that's six months
man
six months straight right damn that's a
lot it's all how you look at it so to me
I was looking at like I've been doing
the six [ __ ] months bro you know what
I mean yeah like a king bro so I went
back to Orange County back to Santa Ana
for Alice Alice in Chains was playing at
the Irvine Brent Events Center was like
it was their theater and the collagen
warmer
that overhand knife right I was in a van
with all my buddies and they heard about
me doing karate and we're in a van on
our way - Alison chains yeah like man we
hear you're doing karate I was like [ __ ]
yeah yeah and they were [ __ ]
impressed really I was showing on that
knife overhead knife strike I got I like
the reverse punch - boom yeah I'll come
at you straight to the solar plexus you
know knock the wind out steel Anya snow
once they were impressed then you're
probably like oh this is cool cuz it
makes my buddy man yeah yeah my they
were so impressed with me so we get to
Alison chance I go upstairs to go to the
bathroom and when I walk out all my
friends are looking for me they're like
coming at me like in a mob going there
you are
there's some guys down at the marsh but
they're starting [ __ ] so they left this
situation to come get you to come get me
okay yeah baby and then they got me and
I was like let's do this man I was what
I was leading the pack walking down the
steps to the to the floor going where
they had think I'm gonna hit him with
the knife and then we're gonna go
straight to those Santa plexus I'm gonna
hit him with a knife I was like so
dragon you can't you move dude luckily
when I found them cuz they would have
[ __ ] thrashed me probably luckily
luckily you would have been it would
have been one of those stories with the
old friends get you know when your old
buddies get together yeah like every 10
years and you always remember that one
story I remember that one story they
would have never forgot that one storm
dude we had a story one time this kid
had a birthday party at his house right
and uh and his parents got a sauna or
not a sauna what was a thing of hot
water in your yard what's that thing
Jacuzzi jacuzzi okay so his parents got
a jacuzzi dude in Louisiana first of all
all of Louisiana is a [ __ ] Jacuzzi
right the entire state is made out of
jacuzzi right you can step in your front
yard but it's so we're all in his yard
dude and night it's 95 degrees outside
we're sitting in the middle of a hot
yard 90 degree water right just boiling
for my buddy's birthday party right just
[ __ ] bacon just buddy soup you know
we're just celebrating his party because
his parents got it's [ __ ]
well some kid in our school I had
learned how to jerk off and the rest of
us had never seen it right so this dudes
like secretly jerking off under the
water you know and and and this guy was
like 30 years old he shouldn't been in
school anymore like got a certain this
one you could just stay in school until
eventually you got you know you got a
job as I could janitor so yeah you know
you come this like eight you know you
come to eighth grade or sixth grade for
the 15th time and finally like you're a
[ __ ] janitor yeah you're high you
know you're not at school you're over
here by the brooms you know and anyway
this dude had been jerking off under the
water but nobody knew then he stood up
and it started just ejaculating into the
[ __ ] jacuzzi right none of us had
ever seen this we didn't even know this
could happen right so everybody thinks
that this guy CJ is melting out of his
penis like like he was just get it was
gonna keep happening until he just got
smaller and smaller and smaller
yeah and just disappeared so this kid
named will grabs on to his penis to stop
it from [ __ ] what yeah and you know
that hurts dude if you're a jack elating
if you're supplying it now yeah it's
best if yeah and they weren't even that
close they weren't even that go-to
buddies you know if a buddy maybe grabs
what your penis when two hands little
different some guy you don't super know
that well yeah and he didn't have real
strong grip so it was still kind of
happening you know yeah you got to
squeeze at the baby no yeah he didn't
have a lot yeah this guy this wilt kid
didn't have a lot of technique the best
[ __ ] would be like to take that knife
strike and just go up on your progress
straight up oh right there pass you shut
it off no this kid this kid had no plan
he went straight for the very end of the
penis two hands stop the the semen from
flying out and this kid just [ __ ] I
guess it could have been an overhand I
strike right into his neck bro and that
kid was never the same the kid that got
hit so can you even imagine holding
somebody's dick you don't really know
that well yeah and somebody hit you with
a [ __ ] overhead knife yeah baby
could've turned it around when I was a
kid in my neighborhood with all our kid
with all the kids around we didn't know
we didn't call it jerking off we called
it plain with yourself
oh really you were all
like damn you're gonna go play with
yourself I'm gonna play with myself you
know we were just and there was kind of
cool yeah I gonna go play with this it
was it was no big deal at all
Wow there was another shame no shame we
were proud of it how right it felt and
we didn't understand orgasms you know
we're like 10 or 12 I just I just
stopped you got tired right did it it
felt really good and then you get tired
yeah and I hated that [ __ ] I I remember
sitting I remember a headset when my
friends gone wouldn't it be great if you
could play with yourself and you never
got time yeah yeah how do you get tired
because you'd not but nothing would come
out oh yeah yeah if something goes out
then he go oh [ __ ] yeah but that's them
Casper's dude is going cast we went to
Catholic school and catechism you know
we even to regular school but catechism
was once a week you went to like a
Catholic school to get your first
communion mm-hmm and you learn how to do
confession and all that [ __ ] and man
that freak me the [ __ ] out when when
when you heard that it was bad to do
that oh at first I wasn't sure cuz like
I wasn't just last my my buddies uncle
who ended up being gay and we're now
looking back on of course he was gay he
ended up moving a Frisco and and he's
out he was all into barbra streisand
right it was obvious but I didn't know
back then I did right I didn't know if a
guy is into barbra streisand he's gay
right I know that right just like he
liked my music yeah I had no idea and
but anyways I asked him I said he's
playing with yourself a sin and he goes
oh yeah for five years goes yep
you're gonna have to confess that like
how the [ __ ] am I gonna confess that
yeah to some strange priest you know in
a dark age and now it's dude I was
sweating it was freaking me out
so you you they're talking they teach
you that what you said you say all your
sins and then at the end you say please
father forgive me for all these and my
past sins right and then he gives you
like your homework seven Hail Marys for
our fathers and they you have a list of
prayers that you gotta just hit and um
so I asked my catechism teacher I'm like
you know that part where it says forgive
me for all these and my past
does that come does that get does it
cover because it only covers the sins
that you don't remember like [ __ ] god
damn it
you remember there are some like [ __ ] so
how am I gonna [ __ ] go looking for a
loophole exactly so so I would practice
I would practice outside
I lied to my mother I stole candy I
fought with my brother I played with
myself I yelled at my grandmother you
know I was just gonna blame if I could
just but I you had to practice that [ __ ]
you know what I mean cuz I didn't want I
didn't know if he was gonna ask
questions of oh yeah hold on hold on
hold on
oh yeah would you say what back it up a
bit you you what with yourself the crazy
thing I you know I would just blow past
it and I ended up becoming an altar boy
Wow at the firt my first stint as an
altar boy and he had a neighborhood
church my first dent was to get to
heaven for real I believe you know I
believe in all the Catholics yeah
they're all that [ __ ] and my life sucked
so bad at that point like this is when I
was like maybe eight nine and ten that
me and my friend Matt my best my first
best friend Matt we were both altar boys
were like we're going yeah man we gotta
get we were just like we're going to
heaven yeah and then going what's funny
here yeah once once my priest asked us
if we wanted to go get ice cream and we
were like [ __ ] yeah let's go get some
ice we were like hell yeah we didn't
really know the priest molest kids yeah
and this [ __ ] was throwing game
at us was he really yeah is he hammered
you look like he was bald you know yeah
you know he's I'd I would say he's like
a 707 okay boy a Santa Anna nine okay
you know anybody know priests know he's
a white guy white guy and a sister ice
cream we were just thing about the
[ __ ] ice cream you're kidding me but
when we told when my friend mattes and
found out she was like oh no no no I'm
going with you guys says she [ __ ] block
she went and he's all [ __ ] pissed off
but he never he never could he never had
game right he never had real game
because he just threw the ice cream he
never threw it right you have a [ __ ]
over him knife striking
he had no game so um then I found out
that there was other religions there
what's a Jew and there's all these other
religions what's a Muslim and then I at
like 11:00 I thought okay there's all
these other goddamn religions I thought
everybody was Catholic right but
everybody in my neighborhood was
Catholic or and the Catholic holidays
you know they coincided with what you
see on TV yeah Christmas specials and
[ __ ] easter specials so I thought
everybody with Catholic then once I
found out that there's all these other
religions that's when I became atheist
right away really there's no God you
know how do we know where we got the
truth you know and they're saying that
you know like born-again Christians are
somehow well how do you feel now about
it so I became atheist and started
writing satanic lyrics and [ __ ] like
that got into Slayer got everything evil
a shot at the devil Motley Crue do all
that [ __ ] start and then I got into beep
then we got into the the German thrash
scene to a super satanic the German
thrash scene was sued yet world war ii
was cuz oh man so I really went balls
deep into that thinking that no big I
bought her a satanic bible so i could
write lyrics and [ __ ] I started you know
my right so it fit with your whole vibe
I was like [ __ ] God and all that [ __ ]
well what do you feel about it now do
you think um well I'm sorry get to that
then I'd be deciding to become then I
was just like a thief you know my mom
didn't have any money we didn't there we
had a steal we had to go to department
stores you know steal [ __ ] steal Andy
just steal you know little [ __ ] I can be
and and then we decided we decide I was
so pissed off at the church I'm like you
know what we'd still go to church though
and we see these little collection
little boxes where you go in front of a
statue and you put like a a $1 bill or a
$5 bill and then pray like that were
like getting money go these
[ __ ] stealing money these you
know I was mad at the church so it was
me and my friend Matt we decided why
don't we figure out how to open up that
steel box and take some of that money
and go play steel box I know that's what
it's yeah yeah let's go bucks let's
let's go play miss pac-man we wanted
some like yeah you sort of handy money
money handy money
yeah and video games miss pac-man
Stargate that kind of shows when you're
a kid that's what the
that is money that it's money that's the
world to you because other kids have
that money like that's all it was I
remember at recess like my friends could
go to the candy window and buy candy and
I couldn't yeah and that determine we
were a kid if you had money or not that
was that we got you we had to get candy
yeah babe baby Ruths all that chefs
fries you ever have sprees no I wasn't
that everything so we would um right
before they closed down the church me
and my friend Matt we'd be sitting in
the pews and we'd have like screwdrivers
and [ __ ] in our pants and as soon as
then we would dip out under the pews and
hide and wait for the security guy to
close the doors Wow you know they would
lock the doors and then the church was
gone Nicolas Cage the church there's
like Ocean's eleven Asian so soon as
soon as soon as we were in the church
and it was locked up but you could
easily was one of those you know the
doors that you could boys you know yeah
we just you know but they're locked it's
locked from the outside so we would open
up those little steel boxes and take
like three dollars and change
we man if there was a five dollar bill
in there man we'd go straight to the
liquor store where they had video games
we played pinball or whatever buy some
candy and or Stolp and then after a
while we thought hmm where's the real
money in the church the real money was
when during church when they'd have the
collection plate in a hitter's no that
was were robbed and all that and when we
when we were both legit altar boys we we
would help out the priest we would take
that money in the back but we never
thought of dipping into it right you
know Anna man so we thought
damn we should be are we too old to be
altar boys so now we're like 1213 we're
like let's start being altar boys we
would be altar boys just so we could dip
into some of that money so what we do is
we would man s yeah that's pianos yeah
after church we would get we take our
robes off and they'd be like a little
hallway where all the rows run and we
pretend like we left but we would be
hiding in the closet and we would just
stand hide in the closet and to the
priest locked up and everyone left we'd
come out of the closet we knew where
that plate was cuz they they just left
it there till the next morning and we
grabbed my ten bucks or whatever and
then we go play video games we did that
all the goddamn time we were going to
church every day my mother's in politics
mom was our mom's were so proud of us
I bought my god our kids go to church
every day like hell yeah we go every day
we play video games every day do you
ever notice that you are getting
cavities from all the candy and that was
just we would sit there and we were just
like so like not into God or anything
would sit there and it's quiet and there
was a bunch of all people ready to die
at church this is like Wednesday night
right now they're going every day
they're ready so we would we would um
lift on with the funny thing for us we
can't be up in front of the church
sitting there with the priest laughing
so we were sitting next to each other we
were trying to make each other laugh and
we would say we would go third row to
the left fifth guy on the right and then
we would but it would take him a while
to figure that out
and then we would have a nickname
already for this man and we would just
have a nickname like one nickname I'll
never forget was this like dudes like a
hundred and five and he just had a
gigantic head and it's he's got all
these warts and giant things on his head
gross I said gross I said fifth row
second guy on the right you could look
it would take you out of fighting you
know so we were trying to make each
other laugh and then we got caught they
figured out once after a while they
figured we weren't taking all the money
just enough to play like maybe told I'm
sure they figured out of the two shady
so they let alterable they still made it
they didn't know who's [ __ ] taking
the money so I figured eh so they left
the note one night we went in there was
an ogre please whoever's taken this
money please stop Wow whatever we took
the money were gone so one night then
they finally figured out it had to be us
so we were hiding in the closet and then
instead of hearing the door slam the
priest you know when the priest left we
heard his footsteps walking down walking
down it was like a lot of closets and he
was opening up closets and you can hear
him moving [ __ ] around the closet it was
getting closer and closer to us work oh
[ __ ] worth of that film of the kid no oh
here's God he's going through all the
closets the bed she's gonna get to us so
we finally opened up our closet
and he opened up the the robes and I
went out ooh
and I scared him and I looked at Matt we
scared him we scared them and then we
just ran out and he didn't chase us or
nothing we just ran out and we took off
and we never went back to church ever
again so you just thought oh he thinks
we're trying to scare him but he
probably realized no no no that's all I
had
what am I gonna say so it was like boo
we scared him look we scared him and we
just ran just like wow
like we were trying to scare ya and they
never came after us oh yeah they figured
it out they figured it like what an ass
will get steals all our money in this
yeah so at that point we started taking
those nickels and started hammering him
and making quarter video yeah we're like
[ __ ] we were we had to good for a
while now we had a we gotta go back to
the end I need to go back to the think
tank yeah yeah but but the god thing so
I was a full-blown atheist up until I
was 21
hmm and I had moved to Hollywood right
when we moved to Hollywood me and my
buddy the the guy moved up there with
we're walking up sunset and he's like
maybe 20 yards in front of me and you
know it was just not every weekend every
weekend were just we're just there to
find a girl right Jason leg that's it
that's all that was yeah so he's walking
we're already it's we're walk we're
getting there right in front of the Roxy
there was this hippie dirty hippie beard
smelly dirty guy playing guitar yeah and
he had this sign it was all about like
save the forest you know you know X
amount of trees are getting chopped down
every day we need to save the forest
yeah I think they call him auntie for
now no auntie fuzz is actually fascist
they're just pretending to be not anti
fascist it's it's anyways but I look I
walked right by him and I looked at him
and I'm thinking and I got my hair down
to my waist it's all I took 30 minutes
to blow-dry it
it's all [ __ ] perfect right looking
like a dude's from Death Angel like a
Moodle man Chris Cornell my hair perfect
took 30 minutes to call down on my way
son you know the big hoop earrings and
[ __ ] I was ready
was the get on big hoop earring good
this was between 88 years between 88 and
91 damn that was just the magical year
for anybody mad long and hard for
anybody that had long hair you know what
I mean so I looked I passed this guy and
I'm like man I'm thinking anytime I see
a hippie like that I'm like dude all you
gotta do is wash up you got the hair you
have no competition just [ __ ] blow
dry that [ __ ] wash it and that's what
I'm thinking I'm like damn he's just
wasting his life and as I'm thinking
that as I'm passing by he stops playing
just walks up to me and he says if I
guessed your birthday will you sit here
and listen to me like yeah right and he
looked at me said may May 15th and like
what the [ __ ] how was that possible was
he your birthday that is my Wow and I
thought maybe you got lucky and I said
John John my buddy he's like 20 yards
out
come here come here come here I said
just his birthday and he looked at me he
said March 31st [ __ ] you know the odds
of that happening yeah and then he
started these are talking about the
forest and all this [ __ ] and all I
didn't listen none of that [ __ ] all I
was thinking like how the [ __ ] did he do
that and how did he do it
I don't know I don't know but there was
to me to me there was only to two ways
he could have did that some divine
intervention like some like there's some
like some guys can see thoughts so yeah
yeah we talked about my birthday
maybe I projected it and some guys can
see thoughts or some boys some kind of
divine intervention told or entity or
snot something to hold him that's the
only those are the other so from that
point on I'm like okay there's more to
this life thing know me know right where
where this is not just there's some
other dimensional type [ __ ] going on
here right you know anything at that
point we're not alone yeah so at that
point I thought okay maybe there is some
kind of spirit thing going on so I was
open to it that that just blew my mind
now and if you don't get open to that at
that moment then you don't want me cuz
you now you know you're -
expand it in the way that things are
possible or things or you know you
question alive believe in a creator now
oh now now I I've done enough drugs I've
seen it yeah I mean when you do when you
do DMT oh yeah you know that there's
other that when you do five grams of
mushrooms you see the other dimensions
you see them and that's not in your head
like ah it's on you're like dude there's
no way what I'm seeing I can create if
I'm creating a [ __ ] right the [ __ ] that
I'm seeing when you're not in that zone
it's perfect yes it's perfect and it's
not breaking apart if I made [ __ ] would
just be breaking apart or I can't even
draw I can't even draw right how the
[ __ ] am I making that I'm making that
[ __ ] up in man no I'm not I'm plugged in
to some [ __ ] that already exists and I'm
able I'm on the same frequency and I
could see it when I close my eyes when I
close my eyes like frequency riders yes
so you should have a show called
frequency riders where people do drugs
and then you are like the sure pilot
you're like they're like the tour guide
that's a shaman it is hell no have I you
know what I'm I don't um I'm not the
type of guy that like I'm not doing
mushrooms like I haven't done mushrooms
and for you do it you know when you're
28 right when you're 30 when you're a
grown-ass man in a safe environment not
out partying or anything yeah an
ayahuasca ceremony might might be a good
thing for you I'm just or or five grams
of mushrooms in a nice safe environment
when you're 28 when you're 30 when
you're older when you thought you
figured it all out and then you see this
and then you see what happens damn you
it changes how you live your life
because when you truly believe that
there's no consequences for anything you
do and because when you die you just
turn into dirt and there's that's it and
it's just over if you really believe
that then then you have energy what a
dangerous
you're dangerous and we don't need that
you need to know that I firmly believe
that there is a creator
there's a cradling on and I believe that
the Roman Catholic Church was created
because it was a way to discredit the
Creator mm-hmm because everybody like
it's an it's in your instincts to
believe that there's a Creator under God
and there's no way to shake that from
the masses the masses feel that there is
a creator and their God so instead of
battling that the smart thing for an
emperor to do is like yeah yeah yeah
yeah we got the God we got the God right
here we got the God right and then dress
it up all stupid and [ __ ] so that you're
either gonna fall for it a god that they
created I get Jesus but they're like put
all this extra [ __ ] on them so that
either you believe it and you buy it and
if you do we're gonna use you to conquer
other countries because we're gonna use
the God for it
that we that we creator our God our
version of it or if you don't believe it
because it's so stupid on purpose then
you're gonna come to the science and
where we have that [ __ ] cover to so we
got both ends and it causes division
which is great dividing conquers a
beautiful thing so I believe I believe
if there was a gun to my head I would
really I would I would send they said
tell me what you believe right now based
on your life experience I would say
Jesus was a real person and he was a
super enlightened smart [ __ ] and
he was powerful in his teachings and cuz
if he didn't exist the Jews would say he
didn't exist if he didn't exist Muslims
would say he didn't exist I would say
that guy never even existed there's no
proof that he existed
cuz they ain't down for Jesus yeah but
what they're saying the Muslims who
don't like Jesus and the Jews who don't
like Jesus they're saying yeah he
existed you know there's enough evidence
but he was just a regular man he's not a
God he's like a son of God right you
know you guys are [ __ ] for thinking
that you know so just that alone I'm
gonna go gun to my head he was real and
what ended up happening was people
believed in him and believed in his
teachings so the smart thing for the
Emperor's to do is like okay okay we're
down with Jesus we got Jesus right here
but this is our version of Jesus right
you know what I mean Roman cleared in a
bar they can control really they were
there evil we have people that created
the Roman Catholic Church I believe
vatican and if you look at the vatican
there's so much loose dark arts and
there's a lot of Luciferian [ __ ] going
on why is your term self areand and the
Vatican hang us on the Vatican but as
always throughout time controlled space
knowledge and astronomers were always
from the Vatican the Vatican had they
have the biggest most advanced
telescopes they call their their main
telescope Lucifer and then you start
looking at all the [ __ ] they do their
[ __ ] kids left and right and no one's
going to jail and they got all this
Luciferian all this Babylonian Egyptian
people people they they were you know
they worship Egyptians like a like you
owe the King Tut - MS oh it's on tour
let's go see King Tut do you know that
he had like eight hundred wives and most
of them were his daughters and ancestors
come on man you're gonna worship a guy
like that there's a dirt ball come on
come on the guy come on King all those
arrows yeah although I went to Egypt and
I'd learn all that I wasn't I was inside
the Great Pyramid of Giza or whatever
the [ __ ] it's called I was right there I
went through all that [ __ ] and what and
every Pharaoh there they all marry their
daughters and their sisters and that
hunter wasn't a lot of hundreds of life
oh but people say oh it's okay because
they were trying to protect their
bloodline it's it's normal they're
trying to say that that's what they said
but dude do it but the problem is
sometimes there's nobody else around
dude like in a lot of areas where I grew
up and stuff like that keep like will
you marry your first cousin yeah cuz I
walked four hundred miles and nobody
else was around cuz nobody one cousin
cousins one thing go catch your
daughter's you have to settle on I guess
not you're saying you ain't marry no
goddamn daughter and yet they're revered
and the the Egyptian culture is revered
in there they were all run by these
pedophiles that not only pedophiles but
their own dollars of power there's an
infection of power was that okay how is
that snot okay but I and when you look
at the Vatican they can it looks like
you know based on what I've seen it
looks like even like we'd like
Washington DC has all this ancient
Egyptian [ __ ] like it never died they
just it's just you'd think it died but
it turned into the sea
societies and and the it's like the
Vatican is like a big front its Vatican
is pretending to be about Christ that's
what it looks like it looks like they're
actually they're actually Luciferian
that's what it looks like and they
fooled us all
that's what it looks like to me well I
think there's some people in there that
you know that that could be the case you
know I think if there's some people that
probably isn't I think it that's where
like you know the battles always there
of like good and evil like in everything
are you aware of all these priests I
don't know if you're aware of this cuz I
know a lot of free idea is it's like
hundreds and hundreds of Cardinals and
bishops and priests are resigning and
disappearing right now because there's a
giant on the middle of this gigantic
Vatican Catholic purge well there's a
lot of hurt like what would even that
Olympic guy Larry what's his name he got
busted and that guy was touching all of
the I mean you know there's definitely a
there's something wrong with a lot of
this you know people that are touching
children there's just something that's
you know there's some illness out of it
in it and I could see how the church is
a place to hide for it because you have
this these weird ceremonies in the stuff
that make you look okay and you're
almost protected at a distance because
you know people only come to you with
problems so they're at a place of you
know where they're bowing down to you in
a way or they're automatically you're
put on this weird pedestal you know like
I could understand how the church is
like but any infection of power too much
power anywhere it all gets things get
corrupted I think um it's ridiculous but
I think Jesus is still like a great you
know if he's the son of God I mean I
think God could add a cut you know a
couple different kids you know like
Buddha maybe some of these other kids
you know maybe they had a weird family
maybe Jesus never claimed to be the
actual literal son of God right you know
he's just saying maybe maybe he's saying
look I'm just maybe just got lost you
know I got thrust and yeah you know like
you never you never said that I don't
know I don't know I think he's a good
role model I think if you believe in a
heaven you believe in it if you believe
in it then it happens when you die
that's what I think so it's up to you
you want but not believe in it you want
to mill around and just be out here
juggling and all of this and learning
you know doing stunts and [ __ ]
eating sushi off a hookers bodies at
fancy parties or whatever do it but if
you want to believe in it then it'll be
there for you
so it's really in the end it's up to you
you know I do know this though we got
some calls we got a bunch of stuff that
came in for Yeti so we want to get to it
cuz we want to honor some of our fans so
yeah obviously life you know it seemed
like listen to some of your life like
it's definitely you know it's been a
battle you know it's been a battle and
not in a bad way but it's like do you
realize now you start to get a little
bit older you know you and I our adults
that that the funnest parts even though
it's the scariest parts and it's the
drama and the grid of growing up and
even though sometimes it's not even
enjoyable that the journey is that's
where the [ __ ] magic is yeah
absolutely I wouldn't change a thing
you know there was a lot of pain growing
up but everything led up to the birth of
my son so I wouldn't change a thing you
know what I mean yeah in dude I was one
of the most jealous times I've ever had
in my life is when you and Joey Diaz
took girls children to where was his
time visiting oh I think I thought we
got the VIP pimp tour can you even
imagine just behind you guys
oh we didn't win any minds man they just
took know after the first or regular or
just someone who's just there at the
park they're in line and they're fancy
you guys and then you guys roll up with
your kids
yeah was it awesome oh hell yeah that is
so cool my son loves scary roller
coaster he's only six he's down for the
scariest [ __ ] we were in Vegas and if
you go to Vegas um at that Circus Circus
they got a theme part inside a circus
circus like a carnival
oh yeah adventure dome she they got some
serious role of coaches up in that
[ __ ] scared the [ __ ] out of me
scared the [ __ ] out of me man they do
some flips and some [ __ ] where he wanted
to go again and I was like I turned him
I said nah you're gonna have to go on
this one alone but then I but then I you
know didn't know he was gonna go on with
his mom okay
but as you get older you get sick sicker
on rides quicker
yeah
so uh but then I I just I said [ __ ] it I
can't let him see his dad go out like
this so I decided to go on him again and
it was some scary [ __ ] he loves so funny
yeah I bet he does you know I cannot
even a Matt I mean I can't even imagine
you having a kid that isn't like yes I'm
going on that roller coaster again one
ride you know what I take that back one
ride and there was no way I'm gonna go
on it was like you know those rides that
go like this
they just swing back like yeah yeah yeah
where there's one that swings it's like
and it goes upside down oh wow it's like
the dragon swing but it'll go upside
down or flip and we watched it and it
would flip and it would just stay there
upside down for like ten seconds and
then come back around like that and he
even said no daddy we ain't doing that
what I think God knew his limit he knew
he knew it's like it's there it's gonna
it stays upside down too long daddy we
have so they got some they got some
fights coming up I want to know you know
I've just been getting in of watching
these fights in the past maybe year so
what do you think about this um do you
think that the Diaz Poirier fight will
happen I don't know it wasn't it sign
and it wasn't son it's confusing
yeah Nick do you know any more about it
from what I've heard it's it's like
agreed upon but like nothing signed yet
yeah and Nate didn't like how I think he
kind of thought Conor was gonna be on
his card so he'd get pay-per-view points
Connor being on his car did sell more
and I think it pissed him off when he
found out he's on to 29 instead to 30 oh
so I I heard someone who talked to
Nate's PR guy like it Palm Springs just
ran into him and he said it's like
really really up in the air Wow yeah
that's crazy
do you uh do you think that Connor will
win this fight this oh it's hard to tell
man part of town you watch them oh yeah
a fight yeah but that's a hard one I
mean it's it's not gonna be easy no for
either guy because Connor has the powers
hands to knock anybody the [ __ ] out so
if he connects if he could stay up long
enough and connect the couple I mean
just one good shot really on khabib
maybe he just [ __ ] knocks him out and
flatlines him but the odds
I mean it looks like Abby was gonna take
him down and yeah do what he does to
everybody just malmo him on the ground
and just I don't know it's a tough one
if I had a if I had to put money on that
fight it would be hard but you got to go
with the grappler cuz Conor you know
he's got to be able to connect perfectly
and it's easier to smother someone and
take someone down and connect that
perfect shot in my opinion but yeah
anything could happen
I don't know I don't know that's gonna
be a tough one it's gonna be a awesome
to watch the Vegas like what is this
from now yeah yeah um you give a
question - yeah who would you rather see
Tony Ferguson face or do you know who
he's gonna face next
that's good question uh I do know who
he's gonna face next I can't say yet
until it's signed is it a white guy or
black eye or a different colored guys
it's also not white or black I can't say
okay but is it a man it is a man okay
just make it sure David these guys young
you don't know you know not I was trying
to look for any clues I could I would
love obviously Tony to fight Conor
that's what I'd like that's the biggest
fight yeah I know that would be insane
training for that I mean that would just
that would be like you know [ __ ]
being a fly on the wall at some like
Muhammad Ali versus Joe Frazier type
[ __ ] yeah what I mean
looking back 20 years from now looking
back at that [ __ ] yeah damn but it
probably happened anyways but we just
have to wait do you see like that we're
gonna get into I mean I was just talking
about this on my podcast this this week
or last week but I don't like it how
people hunt animals from far away do you
think we'll get to the point where
people are actually fighting animals in
cages again like we'll get to that point
with like you know cuz world I don't
think so you don't know I mean maybe
underground some you know billionaires
low-key yes somewhere in China or some
[ __ ] loaf low-key do Daniels about to go
[ __ ] toe-to-toe what a couple of
hahaha but a couple of mongooses over
there under that Panda Express it'll be
nice to see like a chimp versus him
yeah that would be nice oh I think you
know training the chin like actually
teaching him fighting techniques or
chimp versus chimp what about that
oh those deficit imps that are ready to
fight I remember trainers you know human
trainer yeah that would be cool dude Sam
triply would be good at he would know
he'd be like a good promoter I think of
the fight you know he's kind of like a
he could be he'd be like a good Don King
I think he's getting everybody excited
making sure everybody feels good and
rocking it out we had um we had a bunch
of fans that reached out with questions
and and let's get into a couple of those
Nick do you Mon no sir hey my name is
Chris one question for Eddie and a
question for both of y'all for Eddie
Bravo specifically dude I think you're
the man to I just want to know how many
people do you think that the clintons
have had killed not my question for both
of you
his second question was your cheat meal
we are you heard about the McDonald so
okay there you go that filet-o-fish and
I've never known anyone pronounce the O
as poignant Lee either does I respect
that that fillet of fish got me is in my
DNA there you go yeah the first question
how many people in the Clinton body
count woo allegedly there's a whole
bunch you know one recently last week
which is really yeah and you believe
that I mean it's not like Santa Claus
type [ __ ] right it's like just do that
research and you see like holy [ __ ] just
punch in go to Google and punch in
Clinton body count yeah you know well
money's dangerous and power is dangerous
mean those and yeah at certain level in
Clinton Bill Clinton is a certified
gangster him and his wife Bonnie and
Clyde there since I mean they've they've
been brought up that way she got kicked
off the Warren Commission yeah she got
kicked off the Warren Commission that's
how and that was one of the most corrupt
commissions of her and she got kicked
out of that that so they're they're
never always been like Bonnie and Clyde
but do you think we set people up to
like why don't we realize it like with
any pet with it was too much power
humans fail with too much power
never they've always it's it's not like
with too much money too much power it it
you don't just get bet like it it book
it ruins you yeah but they were ruined
from the start
yeah IRA bred for it yeah the reason why
Bill Clinton became a president is
because he was the most gangster and he
did a lot of healing deserved it like
the people running and everything that I
okay let's make him the present because
he's did so much because all all the
drugs all the cocaine in 80's they came
in the United States was dropped off in
Mena Arkansas either looked at a Mena
Arkansas all the cocaine was he was
being dropped off there and give him a
movie about it too
yeah Tom Cruise played they got exactly
the guy was with Ana and the governor
the governor at the time was Bill
Clinton yeah the vice president at the
time was George singer who was the head
of the CIA so there was a big CIA
operation gonna I didn't make that up
this is like real [ __ ] about I do cocoa
Clinton yeah there you go yeah
do you but so if you had to put a number
on it what do you think the number is if
you had a good ballpark it I don't know
man a lot you can pick a couple numbers
if you want I don't want to be part of
that right right on we're a bunch a
bunch a bunch more than 20 I don't know
I don't know take that as a yes but
they're gangsters that's for sure
I could see it and at this point yeah
now I'll say I ask you this do you think
most presidents against Obama with a
gangster super-criminal anybody now
olive who have lyndon b johnson super
gangster I mean he was about to be
indicted on a couple murders before JFK
died and he became president and then
parted himself oh wow they're all
gangsters they're all you can't be
President unless you're a gangster of
course huh well who sits imagine sitting
somewhere right now and being like I'm
gonna be the ruler of the free world but
only a gangster what then yes yeah agree
yeah agree there's just it's yeah it
can't end you have to be careful you
have to monitor what you're doing um I
think that Hillary Clinton is gonna run
again in 2020 what do you think about
that that's scary but I mean I have no
doubt if she gets in man if she gets in
we I don't
think she will get in but I do think
she'll run I do think she will run again
I hope not but it doesn't matter it
doesn't really matter I mean if she does
they got some other criminal if she
can't make it that they're gonna push so
yeah really that I'm not a Republican
I'm not a Democrat but the way what's
you know the the way the left has been
acting since Donald Trump one man it's
scary how much scary how it [ __ ] the
left is there I mean it's ridiculous how
insane and pathetic and yeah well me is
how desperate everybody seems that this
power position is how desperate like oh
we have to have this present like it's
like and you should just kind of seem
like oh one side one once I didn't win
and we keep cruising there's a lot of
crazy [ __ ] going on right yet is it's
right in the middle of society not only
not only a purge of the Vatican but in
the Roman Catholic Church not only that
but we're right in the middle of a purge
Washington DC yeah and the liberal media
they're not talking about it they're
downplaying it they're calling it a
conspiracy theory they're calling Q a
conspiracy theory so if the mainstream
media calls Q a conspiracy theory and
you're on the fence like is it a
conspiracy there is it Ria's it is it
fake or is it real
if what is QC Q is Q is a a group of
military intelligence officers that are
unknown but they collectively drop
information on 4chan and hm and since
last November letting all the true
patriots know what's going on what's
going on because if that didn't exist
the left owns the media right and that
the left is what has engulfed all the
politics and corrupted everybody the
left rules everything I mean the bushes
were corrupt as [ __ ] too but they'll
work together and Q is a group of
military intelligence officers who say
they're dropping all this info that's
gone and it's all coming true so
people think it's fake you guys aren't
paying attention it's it's it's it's all
coming it's it's all going down and you
believe CNN when they say the queue is a
conspiracy there and it's a bunch of
people playing a joke that's ridiculous
it's you know but anyways the queue plan
was it's time to clean up DC it's time
to is this a cycle yeah it's gotten to
corrupt so the queue plan was they
needed someone outside of the political
crimes and the political scene someone
outside who had the balls to take them
down and they recruited Trump they go
Trump is perfect he's arrogant pompous
tremendous ego huge his pride is son but
that's what they need a guy who's not
involved in all this DC political
craziness mm-hmm that has the balls to
come in and make [ __ ] happen because Ron
Paul is awesome everything Ron Paul says
is I agree with Ron but he would fold
under the pressure he doesn't he doesn't
he wouldn't have the balls to make [ __ ]
happen yeah I don't can't even feel any
pressure it's definitely interesting so
I'm gonna get so this is so it's all
gone it's all about is this is the cube
plan fake or is it real so if it's real
if it's real then there is a plan going
on and it's been it's been planned for
years to clean up DC and Trump was
recruited to make the plan happen that's
the plan and it's to save the country
all right so it's either a real plan or
a fake plan if it's a fake plan then
there's no plan right if it's a fake
plan then there's no plan and there's no
hope okay so the the big question is is
Q real or not mm-hmm the [ __ ] hope it
is because if it ain't then there is no
plan because the Q plan is to save us
right it's to save us so you should want
to believe in that [ __ ] and if it's not
real hmm don't worry people are gonna go
you thought it was real my dude I was
just I had Ho
man I hope but it is real and if you
want to follow what the queue plan and
you want to follow the drops it'll get
you so into what's going on in DC you'll
you get to know all the characters and
all the people that are corrupt and
they're getting fired and all these
congressional hearings
it's like Game of Thrones yeah you have
to do once you know the characters I've
never known as much about politics as I
do now following Q I know exactly what's
going on I never did before because
whether there was a Republican in office
or a Democrat I didn't like the of
course the bushes were corrupt as [ __ ]
of course Clinton was it was all up of
course Obama so I was always used to not
paying attention to madness not paying
attention right to politics at all not
ever watching Fox News or CNN not ever
watching any of that [ __ ] I just believe
we're just living in the goddamn this is
all fake matrix type [ __ ] and they're
criminals and they're [ __ ] us but now
there's a plan Q got a plan and when you
follow it you know the bet that the best
way to follow Q is um what happens is Q
drops from all this [ __ ] the plan all in
code is because they can't drop
confidential information straight out
because it's illegal so they drop clues
and they ask questions and and they got
all these people online dissecting the Q
drops and we all get together and the
best guy out there is praying medic if
you go to youtube go praying medic
praying medic he's the best also just
informed talk is great to the pragmatic
man that that guy is amazing and and all
in their cult there's Q drops and then
the a nun all that all the anonymous out
there all the anonymous Anton's are all
these people putting it all together it
really is a it's like a murder mystery a
murder mystery yeah what's going on in
DC and there's some crazy [ __ ] going on
right now no no easy [ __ ] and you know
what if you go to if you want to find
out you got to catch up you got to go q
for beginners and they'll catch you up
okay Q for beginners we'll put the link
yeah it's it's amazing [ __ ] it's it's
hope for for the country well
I get around the country a lot and I
think that a lot of people think [ __ ]
all these politicians that'd that [ __ ]
these people are not gonna run my life
that I'm gonna take care of my life in
my way that's why I think a lot of
people still want to you know a lot of
people the right to bear arms they're
like well yeah I'm gonna have the right
to bear arms because I don't trust the
amount government is having things
that's what the right to bear arms is
about it isn't about it isn't about
protecting your family
it isn't about a hunting it isn't the
Second Amendment is about protecting
yourself against the government yeah
that's what the Second Amendment is man
you think it's about hunting no you
think it's about protecting your family
no it's about protecting yourself
against tyranny that's what it's about
so when they start when people say what
do you need a [ __ ] assault rifle for
and they agree with the the gun control
laws that are being passed dude don't
you see what's going on if the Second
Amendment was about protecting the
citizens protecting themselves against
tyranny and then you see the government
[ __ ] bearing assault rifles don't you
see what's going on
they don't wanna they want they would
like us to have no guns but at the very
least they're taking out the powerful
guns well it is yeah but here's the
thing it's also interesting to me is at
a certain point you're if say if the
government is you know like you know the
politics and the government combine I
don't know the government
the country because those are the two
parties that I say almost now sometimes
it's like politics and then you have the
media and I feel like if they combine to
run the country but then the people who
are gonna serve in the military aren't
or they're gonna need people from who
are do disagree with them I just don't
see how that's all gonna work out
you can't it's like say if it's like the
code of you know generally it's the
coasts that are saying you know that are
more left-leaning and it's the middle of
the country and stuff that's more right
mm-hmm
and most of your service members are
coming from these places that are more
conservative then they're not gonna
[ __ ] I just don't see say if it ended
up in some type of civil war type
scenario these people are
hold their own towns and families you
know what I'm saying like if it got to
that point is it me know who knows what
would happen who knows what's gonna
happen you know I mean cuz some people
out there say oh you want an AR rifle to
protect yourself against the government
[ __ ] they'll blow the why even bother
they got [ __ ] missiles why even bother
like at least you have a fighting
[ __ ] chance you have a group of yeah
armed citizens with serious rifles we
have a chance right we have a chance we
might not yeah yeah the missiles yeah at
least we have a [ __ ] chance that's
what it's about well it's a lot of
things if you change man I think I mean
it's interesting I mean it's it's really
interesting and I'll say this it's
definitely exciting it makes you think
it makes you wonder who you are makes
you wonder where you stand it makes you
question stuff I love question in the
government I love questioning these
these news channels that's why people
are flocking to podcasting now because
they at least want to see if the person
that they're listening to is like
authentic I don't listen to any of these
[ __ ] Muppets on these news channels
yeah none of these people have the have
I don't feel I could have any of my best
interest the news is for me has
completely jumped the shark dude I trust
what I see and I trust my instincts I
feel like the instincts that I have
inside of myself they may be off
sometimes but I feel like that they're
gonna lead me you know to some most of
the times to some decent conclusions
it's weird and I think Tech is the new
fossil fuel people will talk about this
a lot Tech is the new fossil fuel man P
you know it's like you have a lot of the
media always talking about like you know
like or this and that or all that olds
all the old fossil fuel stuff is a joke
man Tech is the new fossil fuel we're
gonna move on because we got some other
questions and I'm not trying to cut you
off at all nope um well we got Nick this
one's super specific so if you don't
have any thoughts on it we'll just go to
the next one you know what's good tab
this is D is from Austin Texas so in
love so I got a question for Eddie Eddie
can I'm not the question but Eddie can
you drop some knowledge on the Denver
International Airport and feel I know
you do a lot of flying as well if you
got knowledge on Denver International
Airport you dropped as well the pretty
suspect place you know
let the people know let me know a little
bit more appreciate it let's be both oh
I have uh I have a really good friend
who his father is uh is a guy that
builds underground bunkers for the
military mm-hmm and he lives in Japan
now and according to my friend his
father tells him that not only are there
military bunkers connected underground
but there's gigantic cities underground
that are connected worldwide that's what
his 80 year old father who's an
architect who builds bunkers he says its
massive underground so the conspiracy
theory that there's all this [ __ ] under
the Denver Airport makes sense to me you
know it's a right central right in the
middle of the United States if I was uh
you know in charge of the military I'd
be building stuff underground every day
or just have [ __ ] Mexicans on the
case every day it wouldn't stop and
according to his father he says that's
exactly what's going on every day
they're building deeper and deeper and
and they have this laser technology that
could they could burn holes through
granite yeah like you know incredible
rates I forget the numbers but they're
just building [ __ ] constantly emits all
underground so and what's that in the
assumption that something wild is gonna
happen on the surface or that that we
just that we should have those like what
do you know why probably just in case
the people revolt cuz the people do have
the power and the people that are
running [ __ ] at the top they know if the
people collectively awakened they're in
big trouble
yeah their hope is just to keep
controlling the media keep controlling
the educational system to keep us asleep
that's what it's all about that yeah the
educational system that's just to
separate the kids from the family and so
they could brainwash the kids and have
the kids fight with their their parents
it's it's um it's interesting yeah
that's what you know you shouldn't be
going to school every goddamn day for
eight hours I barely see my son get kids
in school all day you should go to
school like once a week yeah you know
what I mean
I don't know I knew kids at school once
a week dude and now they don't have any
[ __ ] jobs or anything you have a job
from school to school get you a job
school didn't get me a job it's a good
point I've figured it out on my own you
know
it's a good point what do you think
though that but would you watch wonder
what would you do would you take your
son out of school or no I would I'm
trying to convince my wife to
home-school him yeah you know she's just
on the fence right now we're gonna try a
couple years but I want him homeschooled
I want to be with them all the time I
want to take him with me I want to teach
him I don't want the school [ __ ]
teach him yeah [ __ ] you know what it is
interesting to think that we put all the
kids onto the same sort of vibe to teach
them at a certain level school was
designed to separate the kids from the
family you're trying to run an empire
you want to control the kids right you
don't want a strong family unit yeah you
know what I mean you want them enough
you want him to fight a good rest you
wanna rest that's what the feminist
movement was about the feminine feminist
movement was about separating the family
convincing women that they got shitty
lives when they have the best lives you
get you have you get to raise but your
favorable see what is your favorite
people
those are you your kids are your fate
you die for you get to raise them and
teach them and and and the feminist
movement has convinced women that that's
the shitty job yeah the action should go
out there and have you know work for
corporations really with some of that I
agree with may have the best job the the
fact that the guys traditionally would
go out and hunt or or or work all day
and slave and you know Colm I like the
to think that that's the better life
that's not the better life raising your
kids is the bet the best life they have
the best [ __ ] so well this Select look
this is so there's a you know celebrity
lady out there who's like you know who
many would think is like a like a like a
queen of the feminist movement who I've
Halon well I'm not gonna name names but
who out who's who sent me messages about
wanting to have a family together to
like keep you know like
because that's just so important but I
feel like that they would be afraid to
admit that in their public persona you
know it's like yeah I agree I think
there is something wrong I don't
understand I do feel like there are some
unhappy women out there who have been
led astray exactly to think that but
then also the rockefellers funded Center
and the feminine feminist movement they
funded it they know exactly what they're
doing the plan that was being a mother
is the best thing it is it the plan is
to [ __ ] up the family what's the best
family mom raises the kids dad's working
pull they're all tightest right but then
if we go back to your instance even
yours or mine it's like the men weren't
treating the way a lot of men were not
treating women well and so and then
women didn't have the money to be able
to go make their own opportunity yeah
but but part of that part of the
husband's leaving their wives and
fighting was caused by what you see on
TV and in the movies and all that [ __ ]
why they were going sorry everything is
it just seems like everything is
designed to corrupt and I mean I was a
victim of all that I'm not just saying I
was a victim oh yeah yeah I grew up
thinking that men aren't supposed to be
faithful yeah I was brainwashed to think
that yeah how's brainwash the thing if
you have a girlfriend doesn't matter you
just go out and do whatever you do
monkeys do it you know why can't we
write I was brainwashed and you see it
and all the music videos and MTV and
you're watching videos and all these
girls and you chase that they got me
hook line and sinker and that affects
the the mayor effects marriage yeah and
the kids all that [ __ ] MTV [ __ ]
everybody up you know and I think if and
it was strategic it was strategic they
strategically tried two or extra
strategically tried to separate the
family and destroy the family and so
many ways right and not just the
feminist movement yet so many ways
music music genres like even different
music genres like will this genre will
this corrupt the kids in a certain way
to cause problems in the family yes okay
they greenlit that operation what about
this genre will it is it bad is it gonna
corrupt the kids
yes attics
I don't know if it's that extensive over
but I do think that I feel like there's
a cific specific operations but I got
names to them operations
it's basically operation kill the family
that's what's been going on this whole
time I do think that there is this
especially like I do feel like there's
this vibe sometimes in mainstream things
that want to take away or something out
there I don't know what it is that yeah
wants to a limp like wants us to not be
happy families you know but also I think
that we needed some correction because
men were not treating men were taking
advantage of the situation because men
had money and men money creates
opportunity and so now that women can
have more will have more opportunity to
have more money I see it now it's gonna
be more of an equal meeting where you
don't have someone holding the money
over somebody else's head in order to
make them feel or behave a certain way I
think that so I think we could be headed
into a better space and and I could be
wrong I hope so I hope so yeah
let's uh let's get another question and
some good ones I know just wondering uh
what you think about that Alex Jones
sensor [ __ ] need you any bra I know he's
your boy and I hate to see people
getting silenced no matter what you know
they're talking about like to see what
you guys think about it yeah I feel like
my first always and I don't watch a lot
of Alex Jones I've seen some of his
stuff before but I felt like that it's I
felt like it's it's wrong to determine
in some instances like what is hate
speech without having maybe some sort of
a national vote or something on it but
these days it's like if you don't have
it's like all of our platforms are
social media a lot of it and it's like
if you don't have that then it's it's
tough to get your voice out there and if
social media platforms can say what they
think is okay or not I don't know I
guess I'm still thinking about it
well I mean if you're paying attention
to what's going on
again I'm not Republican I'm not on the
right but you put a gun to my head
Republican or Democrat I'll be
Republican in a second yeah you know I'm
down for the second amendment you know
that
the Democrats are for gun control get
the [ __ ] out here yeah you know let me
get the [ __ ] out of here
Republicans are for less government I
like that [ __ ] yeah so on paper I like
what the Republicans are saying I I was
brainwashed as a kid like I said MTV all
that [ __ ] me chasing my Rockstar dreams
I was brainwashed yeah I mean now I look
now I look back at I'm like wow I
wouldn't change anything though but I'm
trying to change the future like from me
you know um no I'm not chasing mansions
no more I've turned down three TV shows
yeah I don't wanna I don't want to be on
TV yeah he scares me
hey what if I were to have those TV
opportunities ten years ago it took that
[ __ ] yeah and ran with it I've been
looking for that Ferrari I don't want
none of that [ __ ] I don't want TV I
don't want to be in the movies
unless I make my like you know I have a
couple low-budget movies that I produce
with your friends yeah yeah that's
different that's different you know now
what about but we're now what about the
Alex Jones scenario it's if you pay
attention Facebook Google Twitter all
that [ __ ] or run by the left yeah so a
great where's the worst the news on
Twitter if you go to the Twitter news
feed or whatever there it's all like
none of it comes from there's only one
perspective on there and it's it's not
fair because there's there's more than
one perspective and that recuse about
this the queue is about we need to stop
this and the reason why all the info is
coming out on for Twitter's dying
because of it but you know all the all
the info the queue drops on 4chan and
8chan they have to do that because they
can't drop it anywhere else because most
of the media most of the media is
against Trump
and I never remove paid attention to
Trump I just thought whose is man
Trump's running for president that's
hilarious
and then you keep hearing all this [ __ ]
that he's racist and all I'm like and
then I started paying attention like
damn I want to hear all the racial [ __ ]
he's saying cuz I'm not hearing so then
I went in and started you know looking
into Trump and my words others raised
this [ __ ] he's saying and the you know
there was one thing where he said ms we
got to stop ms-13 from crossing
border because they're criminals and
they're gangsters and they're bringing
in drugs and then the the left the the
media left they reported they cut out
the MS turn oh yeah and they made it
sound like he was talking about Mexicans
ya know powerful that [ __ ] is oh it's
not powerful that [ __ ] what shocks me so
that I started realizing you know what
they're going they're going after
Trump's so hard then I read that really
got me into my West [ __ ] are they doing
like what are you doing on so when you
really really listen to Trump man you
could take his [ __ ] out of context easy
there's a thing there's a there's a
there's a video that's [ __ ] hilarious
of you and Joe Rogan going back and
forth like he's making moves on you and
it was cut out of context to make it
look really creepy you have seen no -
it's hilarious really it's like it's
like some dark [ __ ] between the guys
right it's like somebody's gonna lose
their [ __ ] and exactly what CNN does
to Trump yeah they do the example is
amazing and they do that now insurance -
they do it to Alex Jones most people
think he's a psychotic lunatic because
it's very easy to cut out little pieces
of Alex Jones put it together and people
and I know him personally and when you
watch Alex Jones like for real legit you
listen to him [ __ ] make sense you
know what I mean Joe Rogan was on Alex
Jones on the phone like maybe I'll never
forget this like four years ago and Joe
Rogan said he goes yeah everyone thinks
you're so crazy and everything but look
at you now Alan's like about 80 90
percent of the [ __ ] that you've been
saying all the crazy stuff turns out to
be true you know you everyone thought
you were crazy for saying the NSA is
spying on your email but do you think
Alex gets too far like here's the user
cuz you out you admit it you haven't
really listened to them so haven't you
get from them is is the out of context
yet that's what people don't realize
that that if you're actually not
listening to Alex Jones
like for real unedited you'd be like
damn this guy's making a lot of sense
but if your opinions of Alex Jones are
coming from what the left is showing you
yeah it's easy to make him look like a
lunatic he he can he talks for like
three hours straight and he's very
emotional very passionate anybody that
talks that long and he can go for 12
hours you make it with
with no teleprompters [ __ ] you could do
what they did with they they do it to
Joe Rogan all the time they touch it out
of context and it's funny well you could
also do what to makes enough to make it
look dude you make a cut Joe Rogan up to
look like a psychopath yeah and that's
what the left is does to alex jones
that's what they do to Donald Trump so
once you understand that you've been
tricked you know of course Donald Trump
is arrogant pompous but if you listen to
him he's I'd way rather have Trump than
Obama or Hillary yeah cuz he's actually
trying to he's actually doing things to
help the economy and unless the numbers
are [ __ ] it looks like the economy
is booming
it looks like unemployment is at a
record low it looks like you know and Q
is behind Trump and Q is hope hope it's
interesting so I I have to believe I
have to stand behind Trump he could be
deceiving everybody but I have to I have
to trust the plan and if I'm wrong then
[ __ ] we were [ __ ] anyways right if
this is the whole trick damn that even
proves that the left is even more evil
than we even thought if they they the
hoodwinked us and they fooled us then
we're totally [ __ ] if they could do
that if their level of hatred like I
don't understand cuz Hollywood also like
this is where I had a real falling out
with so a lot of this Hollywood like
idea you know it's like Hollywood is
it's like I come Nollywood you know to
be liberal from my town and then I get
here and it's like you know I'm not even
I feel like I'm not even welcome you
know it's like there's just there's no
perspective there's not a dual
perspective in the media and it's that's
why it's like everybody from the media
there are a lot of are a lot of the
people from the media I'm saying
everyone and that's not right but a lot
of people that work in these work in
these news organizations everything
there's second third fourth generation
people from New York from LA
there's not even any they don't even
know the rest of the countries respect
respect well the way I look at it is the
entertainment we've been brainwashed to
think that the entertainment business
movie business and music business are
actively searching for new stars so they
they put that out like like that's true
so they want all these kids that that
are outcasts from
all these towns around the world to come
to Hollywood and pursue their to follow
their dreams of stardom yeah and and and
I always wondering why why aren't all
the the the big wealthy people who are
funding Hollywood why are they putting
themselves in movies cuz they know it's
a trick you don't put yourself in a
goddamn movie you don't want to be
famous because then you're the target so
we've all been brainwashed to come to
Hollywood and try to be movie stars and
rock stars and they're not looking for
anybody they're not look they got what
they're looking for is people that they
could blow up that they have control of
that are compromised
they're looking for they're looking for
kids to [ __ ] molest that's what
they're looking and that's what this is
about
that's where the reader that's where I
think it's like I feel like looking for
stars one thing looking for kids to
molest that's a different that's not
rates coming out now it's not it's I
mean it look a lot of Dark Arts are
louder than out there how the shit's
coming out right now
the Dark Horse are out there and one of
the front lines a veteran take you know
that meat to movement there's like women
coming out from people that have made
moves on him or whatever but there's
also a hashtag survivor stories movement
going on right now kids in Hollywood
kids and child trafficking coming out
and telling us you know that's going on
right now and when you when when you
listen to these stories now well that's
a funny with any of these stories that's
the funny thing about Hollywood it's
like so much finger-pointing if you want
to point fingers point them right up the
hills here in Hollywood join them right
up the [ __ ] hills because there's we
have here's my thing is we're all [ __ ]
up people we're all broken people this
idea that like that comes out of
Hollywood sometimes that there's no oh
we're all perfect and this thing is
perfect and this place is perfect and
you guys are [ __ ] up because you don't
know or because you're poor because you
that makes me so [ __ ] mad dude like
[ __ ] you you don't know anything your
third your fourth generation you've only
ever lived here you don't know anything
else there's a story that I was an
anonymous person came out and what's
giving just basically a story of them
and the 80s growing up as a kid child
actor they didn't give up any producers
names that I list they were just saying
high level producer alien
singer they didn't in the stories that
are told yeah this the story that I was
listening to yesterday they were talking
about how in in in the 80s never
green-lighting any shows about kids any
reason they could get kids in mm-hmm all
the high level producers and the execs
that's what it was all about
they were just how they just need her to
reason to get kids on the lot
that's how dark and deep it is that's
how dark it and the kids that they
didn't use they would have separate
groups of kids to help them like to help
them to help them figure out what kids
really need and all they did was just
take him to they would just take him to
they'd have him all day and they would
take him to rats
Northern California ranches and crazy
[ __ ] I don't know yeah but also it's
like Idol I you know like Jordan
Peterson said it when he was on here
he's like you know we have darkness in
us and darkness can fester and darkness
can create more darkness and you know
people that humans have done horrible
things and they can and so I wouldn't
put it past us so I think like you say
we have to have hope we have to stay on
the other side of the coin as much as we
can we also have to be awake to what's
going on I do notice man I used to be
like I used to go to Yahoo all the time
like they don't even represent some like
they're not if they're just they're not
an equal-opportunity news provider and i
used to think that they were you know
like i used to go to yahoo all the time
that's my place where i got news from
and now i'm like this is just you know
like I want to be equal I want to be
fair but things you have to have both
perspectives and we need to get more
perspectives out into the open and not
just I think a lot of times perspectives
that that that only know one side of
wood that only know one perspective in
America you know it's [ __ ] up but I
think it's changing and I think it's
good have you spoken to Alex since his
channel got shut down or no yeah no it's
scary it isn't scary yet it's
interesting either either it's it's they
legit shut him down and it's a
terrible thing for free speech or you
know I wouldn't be surprised if it was
planned like that and there's some other
reason and I don't know I don't know but
apparently his he's got an app and
that's where the that's the base of this
show right obviously then he doesn't
make [ __ ] specifically for YouTube or
whatever Facebook he's got his own [ __ ]
he's got his own in the Morse app and
apparently it's you know since they
banned him that's blowing the hell up
his blue so who knows who knows maybe
this is yeah it's like who knows what's
going on I just worried that in any
anybody you have till you get to levels
where it's like you know I don't know
here's the honestly I don't know enough
about the situation and talk about it
but I am sure it's not good and I know
people can get banned but I don't think
that it's good that some people can get
banned like I listen to some other
people and I think sometimes like some
of these I think sometimes some of the
late-night talk show hosts or so so some
of the things that they say are some
other performers that it's just so
[ __ ] up and so judgemental that I feel
like sometimes they should be banned but
then I don't know how like if this you
know I don't know if this stuff got like
extremely racial or what he thought but
I don't know how to learn more about it
let's get another question look at this
guy hey guys I've got a general question
about what are some things you've
changed your mind about as you've grown
older that's given you a much better
perspective on life and something
younger people should also apply to
their life that you've learnt oh it's a
great question do you think Eddie yeah I
mean it's basically what we were just
talking about yeah basically that you
know dedicating your life to being a
movie star or a rock star I don't think
it's I don't think it's a good idea I do
think that after going to like years of
classes in Hollywood years of classes
and seeing so many people go to all the
acting classes and stuff that a lot of
it to me does seem kind of like you're
not gonna ever have an opportunity it's
so pretty so many people just give
opportunities to their children
you know so many of our it just a lot of
it seems to be so grandfathered in in
Los Angeles in the Hollywood in
Hollywood but the good thing is now that
with social media and people being able
to start their own things that that's
changing you know and I think and I
think you're seeing a lot of that I
think people just doing kind of their
own thing and just not being afraid to
be themselves you know I was so afraid
to be myself out here for like ten years
I was going all these classes and I was
like you know trying not to have my own
at trying not to have my accent and like
just trying to and then I did you know
just got so scared and then finally I
said [ __ ] it you dude I'm just gonna be
myself and I just wish that I just tried
to be myself earlier but it's scary out
here people get out here and they get
scared and then people get out here with
their dreams and they don't come true
and then they get even more scared and
then they're afraid to even agree with
people from the places they're
originally from because they think that
that's like at least then they're
holding on to their dreams in some other
small way I see that sometimes yeah Jim
Carrey said that he hopes everyone
becomes rich and famous so that they
could realize that it's [ __ ] yeah
yeah I think you have to be careful how
much money you want to have in the world
how much power like where do you want to
stay you know it's crazy it's like
everything comes with positives and
negatives and for me for me jiu-jitsu is
my life yes the number one focus in my
life I'm doing stand-up just to have fun
once a month maybe twice a month like I
said I'm not trying to have a sitcom I
don't want to do TV I don't want to do
movies unless I do a movie and I produce
it and it's like you know I have control
of it but I don't want to be I just want
to focus on jiu-jitsu and do some
stand-up here and there and I make music
you know at home as well yeah I'm good
with that I'm not you know I'm a
different person these days yeah yeah
you know I learned well one thing for me
is I knew growing up like my perspective
of like race relations and stuff is
different now that I see like a bigger
picture about race and see that some
races don't have the same advantages
like I didn't really realize that I'm
but then also realize that really it's
about finances it's like I think there's
some I definitely think there's some
racism a certain levels but I think and
in certain POC
it's more than others but I think that
that's such a small problem I don't
think there's many racist people out
there as as as much as the bigger issue
is greed and more like classism I think
it's such a bigger issue like I was I
was friends with the poorest kids around
and so they were black and they were
white you know and and and I see as I
got older I see like oh there's years of
like you know things that certain you
know that black people don't have an
America in years of like you know it's
crazy it's like if your grandfather gets
a parking ticket you might not go to
college like that's how close the money
is on some families growing up you know
and that's how close it was in our house
it was like you know one little thing
and Christmas is [ __ ] you know mom's
car gets towed and we're [ __ ] you know
it's like that's just the way it is so
it's like generation after generation of
that some classes some some you know
ethnicities are gonna have more trouble
but now I see a lot of [ __ ] is a lot
more even and and on what I'd love to
hear more stories about that that like
hey a lot of people are [ __ ] doing
good who work hard in America you know I
see a lot of black skin color from
different countries from Jamaica from
England that come to America yeah even
England people like England yeah that
come to America and have high success
you know and it's a lot about like hard
work and I just think that I wish that
that were more the message you know
instead of focusing on I wish we would
focus more on what a solution is you
know but and I think it's a lot of a lot
of my black friends feel the same way
but they can't even get that voice out
there because it's not it's not to be to
be had you know and I could also be
[ __ ] wrong so but that's one thing
that I've noticed the guy who called
NASA question that's one thing that's
changed for me a little bit like when I
grew up I you should be like man you
know black people don't like to work
hard they don't like to do this they
don't like to do that and then you get
all your like oh they don't even have
any opportunities in our town you know
like they're still struggling from like
nobody's got an education for years you
know like you start to see how that can
really how it affected you just see how
it can affect people but also you see
now that everybody has opportunities and
time to [ __ ] just embrace those and
let's [ __ ] move forward you know I
just get sick of the everybody using
this race thing forever and I think the
media doesn't more than anyone um what
else we got Nick I know we've been here
for a while but that's okay
what up Bo this is Davis calling you
from the capital of Texas that is Austin
I got a question for that boy Eddie
Bravo with the Trump administration this
been the newest big thing is the space
force and I remember youth the last time
you're on theö show you had mentioned
how the next big move to create
one-world government is an attack by
aliens is this kind of a prequel to that
happening that's a tough one with Trump
and space force man I'm hoping I'm
hoping the cube plan which includes
Trump I'm hoping that's legit I really
am but when he says stuff like space
force I'm hoping it's just because he
has so much [ __ ] going on that he he
hasn't really looked into it and and I
hope that he thinks that that makes him
seem like a better president because he
is not only concerned with making
America great again
but you know making space great again
you know I'm not too sure what he knows
exactly about space but I'm hoping he's
just pushing the space force thing
because he thinks it's gonna make him
look better you know what I mean yeah I
could see that I could see him saying
anything he thinks is big he needs to
have his hand in a little bits that
businessman type of thing but it's but I
think we got to stay out of space man it
all depends on man the space yeah we
could go really yeah we can go real deep
on space but do you think that there are
aliens um man I think again this is a
long story
if you hashtag go hashtag Project Blue
Beam Project Blue Beam is you know if if
you study history and politics
especially in this country you know that
the New World Order is real I mean
George senior talked about it all the
time you could he's like now it's time
for an Ordnung a new world or it's like
a new world order this a new world order
to that and it's all about [ __ ] one
government so if we're gonna go with one
government right we got to give up our
our Bill of Rights right every country
we got to give that [ __ ] that's what
they want they want to killed Mac is
those Bill oh that the Constitution is
huge
yeah the Constitution that's it gives us
power well if they want so so if the
goal is a one-world government
Ronald Reagan has said at least eight
times Wow
George Singers now he's vice president
now we have Ronald Reagan as the
president and all of a sudden he keeps
talking about how if if in front of the
UN in front of the UN Ronald Reagan you
could even find the Ronald Reagan aliens
United Nations speech he talks he says
this over and over he says wouldn't
wouldn't all our wouldn't all the
differences in the world vanish if there
was some sort of alien extraterrestrial
threat and we would all band together
yes that's what they want that would be
the quickest right to bring that threat
that make us think yeah it make us think
that there's oh [ __ ] they're attacking
that'd be great you think is and we'd
all band together if it were real that a
constitution will go down the toilet but
it would have no rights if we had a
one-world government would be in a
police state that's what's going on
total control but then the bigger
question is them then why does somebody
want to do that
but how about this if an alien should
have could you beat in an alien and in
uh in in fighting could you if you got
into a with an alien some only yes
submission only yeah have you [ __ ]
awesome dude I could see something an
alien it's a long story it's a long
story and there's the guy I'm
of a whistleblower he used to be in US
Naval Intelligence his name is William
Cooper he wrote a book called behold the
pale horse it came out like in 1991 and
this guy had access to all these
documents because his job was to prepare
these meetings for high-level military
officers and he decided a whistle blow
and they killed him they killed him but
before they killed him he had like this
this low-level
pirate radio thing where he's dropped
all his info and I used to be really
really into UFOs I got a UFO I got an
alien tattooed on my arm
so I thought alien aliens used to be a
conspiracy theory I thought look there's
all this evidence that the government's
trying to cover-up alien right but we
don't have that anymore
no I know but it's different now because
and then I would listen people say you
gotta listen to William Cooper man he
wrote that book behold a pale horse and
I looked into him a little bit he was
saying that that the UFOs aren't real
it's really just government craft and
the government's [ __ ] with us so I
never really gave him a chance
and then 10 years later I figured it out
on my own my wait a minute let me go
back to Bill William Cooper and he's
saying he used to be all full blown into
UFOs - he thought it was real because he
saw the documents he goes he in the
cover-ups and the projects and we're
like you know government agencies
investigating UFOs he came to the
conclusion that that was all that was
that was the hoax was let's pretend like
let's pretend that we're covering up
UFOs so that people will believe in it I
say and then they started pushing that's
another term reverse psychology that you
know when you study Jesuits and you
study the secret societies all their
problems all their plans are long-term
they're all long-term plans and they go
from generation to generation or any
good business runner you think of you're
thinking of two or three things ahead
you start to think okay yeah I can hire
this person or let this person go today
or do this or that but how I'm thinking
two or three moves ahead now and you
have to think that eventually about big
societies and stuff like that or
underground societies I mean look I
think one - one thing that's great right
now is I don't care what side of any
fence you're on anything could be
religion socialism whatever you whatever
you
I find right now is a great time where a
lot of people are asking themselves you
know they're asking themselves they
don't trust man I grew up just trust and
everything and now I'm gonna listen no
this is I can't just trust everything
because the the people that are running
things are people and just like me they
are they're compromisable they could be
developed able they're corruptible yes
we're [ __ ] broken people we're made
we we were we no one has ever been
[ __ ] perfect and nine out of ten
times when you get two levels of power
your ego is so infected that there's
nothing that you all you're gonna do is
[ __ ] up you're gonna be so caught up in
yourself I just think that it's
definitely a time where yeah it's like
we can't trust what's happening you know
we can't just got out we just got to get
to the point where we can interact we
can do our own research and we
legitimately question everything right
for real don't just say it actually
question everything and be suspicious
about what you're seeing
yeah on TV be suspicious don't don't say
things that they're a defense attorney
would say yeah say things that the
prosecuting attorney would say and the
government is on trial the media is on
trial no I've never look at any headline
of any for any newspaper use every
[ __ ] all these government people are
all taking each other to court now it's
all every one every single one of them I
think it's blatantly obvious to me it is
I can't even follow it anymore
everybody's suing a cross-examine and
everybody's lying then the next week
everybody's selling a book a tell-all
book and it's supposed to be the best
book and then it doesn't tell anything
and nobody [ __ ] knows it's all a
[ __ ] yeah it's all our own our only
hope is the plan the cube plan that's
our only hope if that if that isn't if
that falls apart or that ain't real then
damn and we might have to move to
Iceland you know I mean that I somber a
lot of shorties up there boy I'll take a
[ __ ] crock-pot up there change the
game boy how to call it warm land every
miles come on I'm not trying to change
anybody's goddamn mind I've done your
podcast twice and both times the first
hour we in timeout conspiracy theorists
not trying to be a conspiracy theory
host I turned down three TV shows that
want they wanted me a greenlit shows
that wanted me to be the host of a
conspiracy theory show I don't want to
be Alex Jones I'll talk about it if you
ask me about it someone asks about I'm
gonna talk about it but I'm not I'm not
gonna be preaching and having seminars
trying to open people's minds I'm done
with that [ __ ] yeah I'll talk about it
but I'm only interested in people that
are already awake already
and people that are on the fence
legitimately on the fence I'll talk to
you but if you're way on the other side
if you're a person that thinks Obama and
Hillary are good people if you think
they're good people I don't want to talk
to you but you go live your own life I
can't talk to you well I think that I'm
not I'm gonna try to change your mind
yeah you're gonna have to figure that
out on your own son well the crazy thing
name is how all these all of these
politicians they're all like buddies it
seems like behind the scenes I don't
know I just don't I think it's like you
say it's a great time to think for
yourself you know I think that's what I
think it's a great time I think for
yourself and if you and it's hot and are
humans the best [ __ ] role models like
are we I just don't we're all [ __ ] up
we're all broken people and I just wish
we all would talk a little bit more of
us and I was what makes us you know
there needs to parent we all needs to be
a youtube type platform that's all about
the truth like the goal is to broadcast
the truth right at the same time though
it's a fun [ __ ] time to be alive
because we need a new fun [ __ ] yeah and
we get to have fun yeah and uh let's say
anything else Nick anything else come
through this is Thomas from Greeley
Colorado
what up Co and Eddie Thomas from Greeley
a question Freddie is I know you're
Bruce Lee guy and you have a couple
jujitsu books out and Bruce Lee had a
few martial art books out I was just
curious if you ever thought about doing
a book more on a life style philosophy
kind of your whole opinion on things in
a way just about how you kind of see the
world
not necessarily conspiracy related but
just life in general yeah I actually
have thought about that I've written for
so far and I think I'm gonna do one more
and it's gonna be a exact basically just
you know like the stores we're talking
about just growing up poor Mexican kid
in Santa Ana listening a heavy metal and
[ __ ] yeah trying to no it's fascinating
to me listen to your stories are fasting
you're a great you're good um you're
very engaging and I could see the right
a lot of the writing be in the same way
that's what my stand-up is turning in
yes just a bunch of stories that I can't
tell in class right because everyone
wants to do jiu-jitsu so you know I'm
bombing every night of digits just
bombing at night after night no one
wants to listen to my stories they
they've worked all day and they want to
train and I'm starting I'm rambling and
they're like coach coach it's time to go
you know in a minute so I'm like [ __ ] I
bomb every night so when I finally
decided to stand up again it had been 15
years and that first second I got up on
stage once I realized the power of the
mic um I um I got a mic [ __ ] ha ha I'm
used to doing this without a mic right
bombing and these people are drunk and
they don't want to do too Jitsu right
away like oh man oh man it's so much
[ __ ] fun unless you bomb when you
bomb that's this but it's it sucks yeah
what but when everything's going great
and people are laughing and they're
entertained man there's there's nothing
more fun really fun and you gotta
remember that too like we're out here
you know we're entertainers you and I at
our core somewhere inside of us are
entertainers do you believe that maybe
maybe we're just insecure and we need a
writer admiration right so no but
something inside of our something inside
of us wants admiration yes yes and I
think I think that's definitely because
I don't know but what did you grow up
with your mother and father grew up with
my mother see you didn't haven't your
father wasn't really around right right
my father's never around either had a
shitty stepdad so I think maybe that had
a lot to do with us wanting like you
know admiration yeah you know because
we're uh I'm sure I'm sure that asked
them maybe we would have grown up in a
Leave It to Beaver type family
right maybe we we wouldn't want as much
admiration you know but for me you know
the whole you know I going onstage doing
stand-up again I'm just doing that for
fun I'm just you know I got an agent
yeah had a manager not because I tried
to it just happened you know what I mean
and I had a meeting with my agent last
week and I said I I don't want the
comedy to affect my jujitsu at all right
I teach Monday through Thursday like you
know like a soldier and on the weekends
I have the weekends off so I usually
teach seminars and I said I'll do one
stint a weekend a one stint a month
doing stand-up and that's it you know if
the money gets crazy or something you
know one-in-a-million chance that you
know I'm getting shop type money I might
do two weekends a month yeah but I told
my agent bring job man that guy is
coming out the new line and neck braces
I heard like [ __ ] it's like if you're
handicapped you can still look [ __ ]
fly as [ __ ] crazy selling at all coffee
selling coffee now yeah but like I said
I'm not
I'm only doing standing because it's
it's fun to talk it's fun to telephone
and tell stories and see and then even
in my own being sometimes like I wonder
if behind my own curtains of even
knowledge of myself even though I like
to talk and you know and I like to share
and I like to entertain that obviously
somewhere in there there's some
necessity for admiration so it's
sometimes like even at our core how much
can we even trust like we can trust our
thoughts I feel like but how much can we
even trust sometimes if what we're
saying in the way we're behaving isn't
being puppeteered by some of our own
even deep hidden emotions you know it's
interesting man it's all interesting
dude I'm not gonna write I don't mean to
wrap it up now but we're gonna have to
wrap it up just because but the
conversation with Eddie broblem never
ends you know if you know Eddie look
you're great you're you're a great order
and you have a you know you have
thoughts and you have points of views on
a lot of things do you not still got to
come take a class I know you you put me
in stuff with Chris one of your teachers
over there and I'm gonna come down there
and take a class with you guys yeah man
some of your students I met at a show
recently
you gotta come down yeah it's a bunch of
nerds man it's not I'm just worried
about hurting my neck on it'll be fine
you get you get hurt every now and then
but it's no big deal
you know what I mean it's just like
getting hurt playing basketball same
rate it's not any any different right
say every now and then an injury might
come up it it's so worth it yeah any
kids do it old ladies do it anybody I'll
date and all they learn within six
months within six months you'll have the
ability to scientifically put people to
sleep and you never know when they're
gonna come up you know my [ __ ] self
to sleep some nights due to violence I'm
not joking for bed that is for bed I
can't even get any rest I teach I got
about a hundred schools worldwide you
can go to tenth planet JJ calm slash
locations find a school near you they're
all over the world I teach at
headquarters yeah do your arm it's
always up early appreciate you coming in
man you're always so you know like so
giving of your time and like encouraging
you know and also I love it man still
invited me to come down and take the
beginners class I appreciate it and I'm
gonna come down and do it and I just
want to beat it too and I have a gift
too I will oh [ __ ] nice nice
what is that no I like this one okay
when you change it up
but yeah it's dope man my friend is
company called hood hats and they swim
make hats that are very specific to like
a neighborhood or a spot so there's no
other place to get that hat you know but
that says well my store try to sue you I
don't know if they are not dude they're
gonna say because we have to sue both of
listen to gif to sue Nick also Nick
Davis that's our producer Nick Nick
should go and take a class sometime yeah
definitely try I took one down I took
like three classes at Hollywood BJJ like
nine months ago but then I switched jobs
and it was like hard to get there but
yeah in the cage and it's always nice
like I said everybody would press that
button you could press that bow yeah
it's just gonna take within six months
you know time flies oh yeah real quick
and the the biggest misconception about
jiu-jitsu is that
you know just a bunch of [ __ ] dudes I
just want to rip people's heads off and
it's not like that because those guys
can't hang with jujitsu because of JIT
so you're gonna lose it's a game it's a
tapping game I'm trying to make you tap
you know you're trying to make me tap
it's like chess and yeah we're just
trying to make each other give up in
these scientific strangleholds and and
joint locks and no one's gonna hurt you
tap out you learning to tap out and your
friends everyone's around but the only
people that could hang getting tapped
out are non douchebags cuz douchebags
can't handle the early stages cuz
everybody that everybody loses in the
early stages so in the beginning you're
just doing the tapping you're doing the
tapping and your goal is like how long
can I survive it for our tap head lasted
four minutes and I didn't tap and then
after a while you start getting in the
taps yourself you like and then you
start getting tapped twice and then you
you got a couple taps yourself or maybe
one night you got tapped six times but
you got two taps or so and then slowly
you build a douchebag couldn't go
through those growing pains they can't I
can't do it they can't handle losing I
love right so what ends up happening is
jujitsu classes are just left with a
bunch of nerds man who know how to kill
people
seriously it's it's own douchebag filter
it's crazy
well they I love that statement or is it
know how to kill people cuz that's what
I mean that's what it is it's what the
future is what all of it is it's what a
lot of things are it's like the future
is you know hopefully it's it's that
middle ground it's being that middle
ground person it's being like I think
that I always say beige power you know
people you say white power I never you
know but I mean like BAE the futures
BAE's you know the future is it's you
know it's multicolor the future is but
it's nerds that know how to kill people
you know that's what it is but it's not
you can't just be a nerd you can't just
not to kill people you better [ __ ]
get here in the men it's not and
jiu-jitsu we don't you don't just learn
how to kill people right you learn how
to kill people who are experts at
killing people who are experts at
killing people killing regular people
you learn that in one month yeah like
one month you'll be like this
easy let's like choke a guy ah but the
jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu is the art of
killing people who are experts at
killing people that's different so work
when you studied your Jitsu and you've
been in the game two three years five
years you're looking at
on their super-technical on how to beat
people who are good at killing people
you know yeah now with no one's studying
moves on how to take out someone who
doesn't have any experience that's easy
it's hard scarf baby yeah this mentally
handicapped kid in our town he put you
in that [ __ ] hard scarf boy you
couldn't get it off this move that hard
Eddie Bravo man it's an honor and a
privilege and thank you so much for
coming in man
thank you I think you're I think just
like Joe said you know when Joe says
you're the hottest comedian around man
and you're on fire you're on another
level I mean that's [ __ ] huge for Joe
to say that and we usually agree on on
comedians you know I know he says dude
you gotta listen to this guy he's
hilarious
or if I say listen to this guy so
generally we were on the same page and
hell yeah man you are awesome and I love
watching man you're funny as [ __ ] man
thanks for just you're you know just
keep doing what you're doing
ain't no stopping you man you you know
you you your get you you are your own
boss and my suggestion is just keep it
that way like Joe Rogan is his own boss
yeah be your own boss don't put yourself
in any position where you know I think
just would stand up and doing a podcast
you're good dude you don't need to get
locked into some [ __ ] ass sitcom
yeah it's funny I start thinking about
that yeah yeah yeah I start thinking
about that slave 16 hour days and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that yeah what's better
than getting on stage and getting that
instant gratification and you're the
writer director and the producer you're
on stage Joe could have been doing all
sorts of [ __ ] but only as emotion he was
always and at first I didn't get it when
I first started hanging out with them
I'm [ __ ] 20 years ago whatever he he
would just he was not interested in
movies and he did TV and goes [ __ ] that
[ __ ] he didn't he didn't even wanna do
fear factor they dragged him into him
paid enough money to do it and luckily
it wasn't like a sitcom where you have
to be there all day right here in fact
it was like they do stunts you can't
really do the stunts he would go in
downtown shoot like a bee stunt or
something he'd be done like in four
hours and I hang out you go dude I'm
gonna go shoot real quick but I'll be
done in three or four hours so that's
the only reason he did that [ __ ] but I
always wonder right and he is not
interested in Hollywood at all he'd
always say Hollywood have just filled
with garbage and
and the people are fake as [ __ ] and
they're all garbage and they're all
trash that's what he was saying yeah I
thought are you sure man we could be
going to them parties man that's where I
wanted to go I wanted to do that he did
and he was always and and I thought you
know and a lot of people thought this
dude like and the the way to go is to do
stand-up until you get your own sitcom
right so I get in the movies and then
[ __ ] stand-up right Joe is never like
that effort Jones like out stand-up is
number one stand-up is where that's my
home base right as long as I keep my
stand-up strong nobody can [ __ ] with me
I'm in control of my own destiny I'm the
producer the director I'm the writer of
my own [ __ ] right and once you start
signing contracts with different [ __ ]
people I mean we had a horrible
experience with the man show on Comedy
Central he was the host of the man show
after Jimmy Kimmel and yeah I remember
all that and and then but yeah you were
gonna be the head writer and he would
they wouldn't let it they try to not let
him hire you yeah exactly it was rude he
wanted to hire me cuz we were writing a
bunch of sketches we were already gonna
pitch a Cass County show like a Dave
Chappelle type show yeah and then they
offered him that show which is a kid
sketch comedy show so he accepted it as
long as you know he had there were
certain conditions and one of the
conditions was that he'd get to hire his
writers it was me Chris Maguire Matty
Kirsch he brought him but they didn't
want to hire me and then you know that
whole story and it was it was a
nightmare like man and even realized and
he realized you know [ __ ] TV that's
realized once and for all right there
the way they screwed him and the way
they treated him and me he was that was
it yeah I get worried about it I mean
I'm not worried about I start thinking
about like yeah I don't need it dude
really you you could you have control
the way what you're doing right now [ __ ]
keep it that way yeah keep it though
you're making okay money right yeah we
just started we're just starting almost
make some honey
yeah but when you go on the road you're
coming back with oh yeah just literally
just started like literally this past
week and you know what there's no
turning back now yeah it's only gonna
grow from here look at all the people
around Joe that have blossomed it into a
full-blown ælis comedians they're all
doing when Joe has your back yeah
he's been released I mean that's I think
I think you're all set to be your own
boss right and I think you should strive
to keep it that way and be satisfied
with what you got you're off a list hard
[ __ ] hitting top of the food chain
comedian with your own successful
podcast and it's only gonna grow from
there yeah you know what I mean I would
never suggest I would never steer
someone into Hollywood it's it's too
dark
right it's [ __ ] garbage you know it
is really scary and I respect you I
respect your opinion man I mean if
there's one thing I mean you do you
definitely kind of a wild cat in some
areas but you are a business owner your
successful business owner you know you
know it's I don't know how that happened
it's like the one thing I learned from
my jujitsu is you know my whole life I
expect it to be a rock star and I never
expect it to be this martial arts
instructor a bunch of schools I never
expected and then in that while you
never expected that never expected that
and it happened that's crazy even when I
opened up my first rule I thought it was
just gonna be just one school I didn't
know there's gonna be like more schools
I never thought about that until people
just kept coming up to me and say dude I
want to affiliate with you I want to
start a ten planet branch you know in
Dallas yeah San Francisco whatever and
I'm like how do you do it having no [ __ ]
I might be [ __ ] and then it just grew
and then it grew and then it grew and
now here I am finally you know realizing
that um you are a rockstar to a lot of
people if that is that is really what I
want right that's really what I should
be focusing on and that's what I have
been you know it's I've been focusing on
growing it and it's been growing and
that's that's the main focus of my life
is it's no longer music right although
I'm still producing right but does that
but your sit you're inspiring a lot of
men you know to be able to take care of
themselves
yeah and I love it man I love the people
that see this turn wo man that's a
that's every head instructor that's
running a tenth planet school around the
world we get together on a chat as you
know every day every that's our secret
society can
and ten WL baby we all get together
every day and we you know make sure
we're all on the same page business-wise
you know even you know conspiracy theory
wise we're all together cut low you know
I appreciate ten planet more than ever
yeah it's you know and I just you know
I'm you know like I said I sat down with
my agent I made it really clear I'm like
I cannot have you know these comedy
dates interfering with much with my
jujitsu so right you just use fern oh
absolutely yeah the comedy is just for
fun yeah I ain't trying to I'm trying to
be on TV
look man I'm glad you're involved in it
because I get to see sometimes um you
know and and it's fun and it's been a
blast and it's been a blast getting no
you know hope you'll come back man
you're the only repeat guests that we've
had oh really oh yeah oh I'll be back
again might be the only one ever yeah
most of those guys are gonna walk Thank
You Man I appreciate that I appreciate
everything and we'll do this again
alright thank you very much Eddie Bravo
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my mouth I can feel it in
my thought it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]